[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right
lords what's going on happy new year
2021
let me know how my levels are sounding
let me know if the levels is
good getting everything restarted
see how y'all doing out there what's
going on christopher
hart daniel my man know that celia
hustling motivate
i'm saying six layer black ronin three
five seven chief
rocker come on chief rocker
turn my headphones off black road is
stupid
i'm about to hit you with them dialog
bars hustle thank you brother
the level's a little low all right right
now i usually start
low because you know i get loud my laugh
my um okay
okay see i'll put it up a little bit
hold up a little bit
yeah i know i get loud with my laughs so
they they they be complaining
[Laughter]
but until my level up a little bit alex
say what's up to the people
hello hello
i had a camera looking like in a hostage
situation but we working on it
ain't nothing i could do i don't got the
lo i don't got the lighting yeah we'll
work on it we work on it
but good to be back king will be rolling
up soon
soft you know evil what's going on
mexican zoidberg what's going on
um yeah we've had this for a while we've
had that for a while there that's
that's the old joint you know what i
mean happy new year
new name mojo what's up brother good to
see you scrub nurse what's up
let's see what's going on now live you
already got i already said you got your
book of x out
david alright is that dj or rose is that
dj
destiny on the one and two happy lord's
day salute
i'll be seeing you out there brother see
you out there doing your thing with the
raise and all that i'd be appreciating
the help you already know
but um yeah man we're gonna wait for
some we're gonna wait for k me and
chilling setting things up for the new
year
and um yeah as soon as we get king up in
here you already know what it is
commuting can uh get things
rolling you know
[Music]
what's going on in here def mobile
akw what's up y'all miss y'all this is
good to see good to see
anyway we will be seeing y'all in a
minute and we end up we will be waiting
for the king itself to pull
up tortilla
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
good thing good night
happy new year and welcome back to the
iron lords podcast and the lords of
gaming
addicts in the bushes
hopefully he will be back episode number
one
90. and it's another glorious sunday
we're back at the round table on the
lord's day
and today we have ubisoft plus and game
pass rumors
the studios we are most hyped for in
2021
potential sony and microsoft
acquisitions and
our most anticipated games of the year
to discuss so we gonna get right into it
i want to start with the young wolf but
where he at
all right
[Music]
[Music]
i'm here though i'm here though that's
all that matters no doubt so let's
introduce the four horsemen of gaming
the original lords of the realm here at
the round table my co-host with the
colmos
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror
lord of his own world and the heart
of the young wolf my man back on zoom
lord addict how are we doing doing
pretty good you know what i realized kim
we're gonna have to stop
doing accomplishments because this man
gonna always put another hyphen on our
intro
and before you know it it's going to be
like a 30 minute intro every time
because
he's saying so much about it how are you
gonna have to stop improving let me stop
it i'm gonna allow him to keep showing
my accolades that's right
let me blow v8
doing pretty good man uh you know
definitely been playing a lot of destiny
here lately i don't
i don't know like every time i tell
myself every week okay after this reset
i'm done i'm good for like a couple
weeks
and it's so this sounds like yo want to
do this right damn
yeah it's a good raid it's a good raid
man it's a good
for sure anything else you've been
playing besides with us destiny all day
every day i've been playing a lot of
apex legends here lately
okay okay i've decided i want to be the
very best that no one ever was in apex
oh
wow got a super chat oh yes sir we got
smitty smith with the
dollar super chat happy new years lords
and chat
salute thank you my brother thank you
bro
and you know before we before we get on
with the rest of the intros
you know it's been it was a fantastic
year
for the lords you know you guys
definitely showed up every week you gave
us that constant support so
this day i'm going to be doing a little
bit of uh
a little bit of trivia in the chat you
know throughout the show we're going to
be giving away
four codes in total nice in our
in our it'll be for the members and the
the channel
uh the the channel members on youtube
and the patreon members
and then what i'll do is i'll drop one
random code for just the chat in general
later
nice that's what's up that's what's up
we got a couple more super chats saw
before i introduced you sure
we got squirrely dan with the five
dollar super chat let's get king in here
first and get him done
in 1.5 15. joke happy new year
what
let's hold it down and run these gaming
streets all 20 21.
that's what i'm talking about man that's
what's going on
unfortunately i will have to leave at 3
30 today
it's cool oh oh hold on oh blaze up in
there
blaze 4k family with the 20 super jack
happy new year from all of us that's
sony here what up family
i like how you play uh i appreciate that
you know
since we got like the only
representative here thank you sir
i like how he represents all of sodi
could you tell sony to make some games
so
playstations turned on
you know after i finished that miles
morales in five hours
[Laughter]
hey hey hey blaze we're gonna be doing
that among us this
this uh on the sixth man i need you in
there so i can
so so i can airlock you man i need you
and on the fifth
on the fifth day i will be doing my hot
chip challenge
oh he's coming back yeah yeah we gotta
get that for wilmington people have
so pop chip challenge on the fifth
i'm gonna go live live i'm gonna be
trying to die
let me know if you want me to pull up
just you know yeah emergency purposes
[Music]
i'm definitely going to try to get the
death on no doubt solve super chats
yes sir we have mexican zoidberg with
the five dollar super chat
shout out to lord sober for hooking me
up with that ten dollar code a few
months back i finally used it and bought
hades with it well done
wow and
of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single-player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord
of clarity and lord patron of the iron
bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing good
afternoon
i feel like you keep drifting to the
left so what's going on
listen it looks like he about to just
dress like it's like somebody's silently
kicking them
that's i i tend to lean to the left he's
like left
so um but as you can see i have not
ascended i'm back from the forest
you have your business with the bad
delorean it's done
it was doing that to me before the
podcast um
let's let's get these two superstars
gerald mack with the five dollars happy
new year glad you're back
my sundays are back shout out to lord
thank you sir hello
yes yes and then we have welcome to the
realm lord david
rose welcome lord gold yes yes sir
salute everybody put those shields up
that's our destiny bro he's been rocking
man salute to him
i saw him all rocking with uh thai guy
travis ign they were doing some raids he
always reaches out to me
and the klan iop clan if we need help
i i tell you um listen man if you see me
on and it's a rare occasion if you
actually see me on
you can jump in my um my parties or
whatever you can jump inside uh
my fire t because somebody jumped on my
fire team yesterday i was like who is
this yeah
we're doing that yeah we'll be getting
salutes now in the tower it's kind of
yeah
what's up dude see you it's like oh me
add him oh that's king david that's
what's good
what else we got we got best stocks fine
it's the five dollar super chat sony
love feeding their fans lunchables
good morning lords xbox for life hundred
percent yeah you guys are early early
with them it's a new year early with the
snow
smoke is to be hacked encouraging them
smoke is to be
had what's been going on what would you
be playing with killing manchester
united
it was been good to be uh off the radar
off the grid for a couple of weeks and
felt good i just got back from a little
mini
birthday excursion so by the way shout
out to lord brat fellow capricorn happy
birthday oh yeah birthday stop
stop stop slide to the right
face the lead like you gotta hurry up
and leave
the ball gotta other way the other way
yeah yeah yeah
oh you're right yeah
do you get like the habit of like
talking when you move yeah
it's funny it's funny because i you know
what it's like because you'd be acting
like you surprised you moving over
out over there like it could be a couple
of force ghosts around me still you know
yeah somebody's just like so that's
that's sony trying to get you out of the
frame
yeah i actually got to play some games
so wait let's go
um i got maybe 15 20 more hours into
about holla
you can't be calling yourself out like
that man i actually got to play i mean i
gotta admit
i wonder right it's one of those things
for me ac i i don't drop basically
but i do wonder if i'm going to like it
or not because it always starts out
really rough
and the combat is like what what is this
comment going to evolve into
so now like i'm chopping people's arms
off and it heads off
and like i think that's i think i liked
watch dogs more than assassin's creed to
be honest with you
i don't know what they mean maybe i
played so much odyssey that i was just
like nope
it's an odyssey will break you after a
while like i
i think i put like almost 100 hours and
all right so i really didn't even finish
odyssey yet
and like i was i get so busy doing other
side joints yeah that i don't do the
main quest then when i get back to it
i'll be like i'd be
i'm bewildered bewildered though like a
half an hour to actually figure out what
i was doing what are we doing yeah
yeah you know it it's crazy it's crazy
but i mean again uh the hollows is great
so i'm enjoying that
i actually played through all of hive
busters ah
yes what's up with that fidelity yeah
that's crazy
[Music]
like in terms of fidelity in terms of
uh resolute like resolution frame rate
the game is gorgeous
a little more i don't know how about now
yeah there we go
[Laughter]
so i did that um let me see what else
oh and i uh will be happy so
i got back to ghosts i got back to those
nice um
the second act i'm near the end of the
second act like something really
crazy oh lord
what yo that game running at 60 oh my oh
you're doing it right too cause you're
doing it
i feel like wow yeah you know what i i
got to get off my bs today
um it's two games that i really need to
you know
and i said it i was going to wait for
the playstation 5 to do it so i
put it in that performance mode no not
even performance no no just off the road
you put it on fidelity mode and it runs
at 60.
yeah with the ps5 i feel like
i didn't know that i feel like with when
it comes to
goes to shashima like i really do feel
like that like people don't give that
game enough credit
like yeah like because i see people like
oh it's got a it's got a
an average story no that's not an actual
average story
the only thing i feel that the game does
i know i think it's one of the open
world stuff
and yeah the similarities again i play a
lot of assassin's creed i've seen a lot
of this stuff
but and but the rest of it like the
production value yeah yeah
the sony exactly is the japanese stuff
like that
yeah all right make sure he's catching
the right mic or something i don't know
again i don't know why i honestly think
that goes to sushima is one one of the
best games they've made
in a long time oh no yeah i would put it
it's literally like the top three of the
best ps4 games
out yeah i'm feeling well i mean it
would have probably won game of the year
for me
for them uh but like i said
you know i don't know the last of us two
one game of the year it's definitely
better than last yeah
so we actually missed we got somebody
joining the room and i believe
we did that we got that no we got kids
no another one we got
oh yeah we got k asante welcome to the
realm oh
[Music]
you know what i think i think i have the
uh i have zoom monitoring my mic
yeah yeah going up and down yeah it's
like like it's solved
we got to dial you back i think what it
is they're down him back when he's
making that slander
they got the gear setting on there like
don't don't
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh be loving lord king how we doing sir
hold on one second y'all see what's
going on back here
stuff is looking really different back
here you talking about the the cell out
getting rid of the dc stuff
oh yeah the dc stuff is packed up and
ready to leave
baby seems happy cece do you see uh
batman batman he he he the last of the
mohegans but he's already you know
somebody already put the down payment in
so you know i guess when he give me the
rest of the money he can get the rest of
his statue
um but uh this
bad boy in the middle over here this
hulk transformation
this bad boy is gonna be the next kos
um and hold on it's the guard in the
building
[Music]
we gotta let me see a new [ __ ] that
statue looks like something i'd cross
the street for at night
yo anubis
uh zion art did such a phenomenal job
i did a double unboxing um i was really
busy over the holidays
uh with uh dcx if you if you're not a
member of the pcx uh make sure that you
go to the pcs
i know it's like it's one of those
things you see crossing down the road
and then um if you look over here like i
did
uh uh grow goal um i did scarlet witch
scholar which is down at the bottom over
here
you know um i did unboxings there uh
red hawk has shipped he'll be here i got
a hobgoblin and a couple of other stuff
coming in and my spiderman stuff is uh
you ain't supposed to tell them the name
oh no no listen they they they need to
know they understand i want them to tune
in and
and get ready for this what's about to
go down it's about to go down
so as y'all see the module cases is in
the other major cases is on the way you
know they pour
pre-op uh you have to uh per order and
they're shipped out
he said that a new business top five for
him yeah thank you brother
and uh that drain is gonna go over here
and then this is all gonna light up i
got all the lights inside already
all the statues was gonna be and it's
gonna be a nice little production on
this side so we're doing a revamp yes oh
yes yes thousands of dollars
excuse me flex
[Laughter]
hold up real quick yeah we got akw with
the five pound super chat
son where's casper but your camera game
is fun
happy new year king sony refund pull it
yeah facts um i want to give a shout out
to king ryan garcia
uh he fought uh uh luke campbell
uh it was an entertaining fight uh for
as long as it's lasted
you know ryan garcia got dropped in the
second round and it was something that i
i
figured one day that we will see happen
if he gets tagged how would the young
boy handle himself
the young boy performed as a champion
trying to become a champion
and he went in on the olympic medalist
gold medalists
and they were uh pitching a a battle
uh luke campbell is a southpaw and he uh
ryan garcia caught him with a left hook
to the body canelo style canelo has been
uh his team has been training ryan
garcia so that left hook to the body
dropped luke campbell he could not get
up and continue
beautiful fight um but i must say this
as as as overzealous as the young man is
he has uh shakur stevenson he has devin
haley
and he has javante tank davis oh he got
your volate over there
yeah and i'm going to say this to him
javonte tank davis is a southpaw
javonte has a better defense than luke
campbell
even though he's shorter he has
devastating one
hit kill you power if he gets into your
section mr garcia he is going to kill
you
he looks to me to have the oscar de la
uh
oscar de la hoya um style and
floor remember this lawyer was fast
powerful sharp and strong but if you
catch that chin
just right
that's what made him so entertaining
all right so i think we're going to see
fantastic stuff from the kid
because i think the kid uh has no fear
so i think he'll be
jumping in just like uh oscar did with
the eye cortez
yeah and and stuff like that and and
we'll mix it up with the tito's and all
that vargas remember all that stuff i
mean
he definitely would do it mm-hmm high
hopes for the kid i hope nobody holds
him back
but if he gets in there with tank my
money on tank because tank is gonna
fold them like a lawn chair
whatever you even play oh i've been
playing destiny with my ray brothers
i'm gonna give a shout out to uh neil
before god yeah i want to give a shout
out to
uh forte gaming forte yes um because i
got a chance to actually game with gamer
forte i wanna give a shout out to scream
i'm gonna give a shout out to sinister
for coming back over to the xbox and
at 60 frames per second i want to give a
shout out to cognito
um i want to give a shout out to all my
iop brother and if you
not uh in our iop clan i suggest you get
there now get on destiny
yeah and we're doing raids daily i want
to give a shout out to attic because
addict jumped in the party and said
i don't care what's going on i got to
get king david that was a very
controversial
statement this week
he definitely i i i truly love
what destiny does it take it took over
what um halo used to be halo used to be
our saturday fun night get it on
and mess in the chat and a lot of people
just come in and listening to the chat
to hear what we're going to say next and
it's so much fun
if you if you're doing nothing and you
see us on jump into parties you know
hang out with us
we we're not bougie and we don't lock
you out fast just come in
if the room don't fill up and have a
good time the ninja is asking uh yeah
the clan's
pockets but it is private so what you do
is you have to hit me or king up
and then we will add you in the dm i
know right now so it's 100 deep but
we're probably about 94.95 so we're
filling up again quick
so you know if you're into the rating if
you went to like i said in philly even
if you're not in the rating you know
what i'm saying
if you want to do other stuff let us
know whatever but spots are limited but
what else
has been a lot of raids a lot of fun
yeah that and
um i was really disappointed with
getting past the second half
i'm not gonna lie you know i i guess i
got you know
uh you know phil dominates max
spencer definitely have me spoiled
so i was like i thought on christmas
they was gonna drop something special i
was looking
i thought on new year's day was gonna
drop something special i was looking
yeah it's like
did they did they put something in there
because i got a message from game pass i
was like oh it was like oh
i was like ran over to my xbox i was
like what's happening nothing
nothing's happening what you got is what
you get
let's play your stuff you know uh cole
vain in them
so um i definitely started that up and
that's all for the respective addict to
be honest with you
um i was playing my my gears uh download
um yeah what's up with that yeah
it's it's a very good looking game
apparently and i really had to play
because apparently there was a
character in there that looked like me
oh they running there
with that character all over you right
dudes was all over twitter to talk about
king david needs to be this guy
he's the dude that give the reloads
you know and i couldn't i had to play
with him so
it was definitely a good look it was it
was fun it's dlc
just like miles morales
[Music]
yeah other than that man i just been
touching up a whole bunch of games and
just
just had a little break and having fun
playing some games
absolutely solving you want to get the
uh joints before i start my
yes sir first off we have aerodymus with
the five dollars of attack thanks so
many for backtracking on believing in
generations because pf5 owners wouldn't
have anything to play who did that for
you
shout out to phil diamond it's maximus
aurelia spencer yeah my
great friend mr bill stillwell for
putting the fear god
then we have andy crawley with the 20
super chat
just to thank you for helping me through
some hard times i love you guys this is
my favorite channel by country mild
cheers
thank you so much man we got something
hooking up for y'all
yeah we're gonna get back in a minute
yeah that's what's up man so yeah that's
been there for the king
and of course yeah we're good no doubt
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself
the shinobi lord cognito spreading that
realism around the ilp
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear
yeah man destiny has been in full force
the over
the old guard is beating the new guard
you know what i said
well it's just so fun the party chats be
like 14 12 deep
everybody having a laugh a good time
shout out to everybody that's been
pulling up coming through
shout out to um back from dead back he's
been showing a lot of love to us
new clan mate sherparing people coming
through and
even though i am very happy that he
helped us i was very envious that he got
isaac tomorrow
the rare rage drop
now he's getting kicked i've done that
i've literally have almost 20 clears
yeah
and i still haven't got that he was like
yo i think i got an exotic drop i was
like you got the damn rock
no the best thing about it is sorry for
eating on the mic
yes um the best thing about it is he
came in to help out yeah
selflessly he was about to help someone
else out and he yeah he came yeah
he came in he had a limited time and he
he got it and
and i and i loved that aspect of it uh
it seems like it's
almost kismet that it happened for him
that way it was like he's listening
he was doing being a good samaritan to
help us out and then in the game we're
more than i've been getting one of them
rare drops
so salute to him oh shout out to gerald
mack finally shout out to iron law
podcast
you guys are the goat for the gaming
community and i being an old head truly
appreciate
hashtag i'm 50. that's what i'm talking
about let's get our old trees up right
here baby
let's go oh geez i'm almost there who's
dead
i'm gonna get that a little bit faster
than you
yeah back from there he's a good dude
yeah he really is man he really is he
he's appreciated himself to ilp destiny
clan and we respect them
for me man like i said number destiny
nonstop with the rating with the team
doing that um still been playing rock
and gears tactics and now
i'm on my um ssd hard drive clearing
mission
so out of uh apparel of the gorgon dlc i
am
75 percent done you must get off my hard
drive i must clear up space the medium
is about to be downloaded
it's ssd business now and next gen
these games got to get done because i
need the space you know
i tell you i i keep looking at that that
that memory card and i'm like
i'm not picks off i'm not doing it bro
i told you i brought four of those sorry
yo i mean the need for it is there but i
am looking at it like damn it no do it
it's not there that much
the best thing is it's like having a uh
a credit card that's you you know it's
it's you know that that joint you walk
in the restaurant yeah
and you just put it down on the table
you're like whatever bring me more bring
me more
and i don't care about i don't i don't
switch stuff around i don't do that that
stuff that y'all
no i feel you yeah i'm listen i'm almost
there man i'm wrong
to me it's just justifying it like
this yes i could literally buy
an s yeah but you know what monday it
was ten percent
yeah you know what i like about those
cards though like when they get cheaper
i think i'll pick one up i like the fact
that
that like when i get a s i could just
unplug it from the x and plug it
straight and just move it yeah anything
you want to play on the s you just put
on there shout out to jason ronald's in
the team
cedric h with the 50 super chat thank
you so much my brother happy new year
lord happy union to you sir he knew here
man
you put it up in that crimson i like
that criminal
you like that color yeah
cedric you're cedric yeah
[Music]
good to be back but uh you know attic
and i and the lord just saw the king you
know
we want to give back we want to give
back man you guys really fuel us
yo listen i'm gonna tell you right now
share this out to everybody right now
call everybody tell them
tell everybody right now i'ma tell you
right now listen you're not ready
tell everybody right now call them i
don't get it okay get on the phone
call your friends and tell them right
now you better three times
someone's to clip that one part and go
crazy with that
you're not ready you're not ready i'm
not ready got all right
all jokes aside you know we we missed
one week and just even for one week of
just taking a little break recharging
the batteries
you know we're really consistent yeah
for real i felt like it felt like two
minutes it felt like two weeks and
people were well it was two weeks from
now
i missed two weeks yeah yeah yeah
but now all jokes aside man you know
it's it's cool to see the love for the
community you know i got
countless dms you know from people just
thanking us
like people i wouldn't expect saying man
you have no idea what
iop means to us to the community you got
all four of you
and the team and everybody that you
represent and log net it's just great
for the gaming community and
we needed that you need sometimes you
need to hear it from your peers i know
king did a
a beautiful speech damn handmade tears
last iop but hearing it also from your
peers it means a lot so
with us as you know you know we like to
give back you know everything that we
get in we put right back into the
podcast so
got something special cooked up so uh
without further ado addict should we
just get into this thing man put your
seat belts on
though all right he's gonna remember the
music put your seatbelts on
let's
[Music]
a
go
[Music]
imma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meto
i know it's my destiny worth the cognito
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues
since a juvenile i've been cursed with a
curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it in
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
welcome
[Laughter]
to the realm 2021 let's go
talk to me real talk to me how y'all
feeling out there man
it is good to be back we figured we'd do
something
a little new little fresh you know
hustle and motivate knew who it was
immediately knew exactly what was that
absolutely
hustling motivation that's it you're
gonna have to readjust
yeah i'm doing it right now i'm doing it
right now dallas you know
saying dallas video shout out to 2xp
level one gaming you know what i'm
saying helping us out
with a vision that we want to do we want
to give it all okay
i'm gonna give i want to give a shout
out to all you frauds that i told y'all
to hit me up to get your verses
in and nobody wanted to get their verses
in so i'm gonna give a hell of a shout
out to my man dallas for coming in
breaking it down and tearing up i want
to give a shout out to sean labrie
for definitely doing all the artwork all
the stuff that was beautiful
give a shout out to addict for all the
hard work that he pulled in fast listen
man i told you
we take whatever money that is donated
that is put here and we put it back
i'm already working on the next intro
for next year
so but this right here it feels real
good so you can see the reception in the
chat to see all you guys you know uh
putting those fired y'all loving it and
we got something else
it's something else too when when to
come wait and scream y'all gonna see
some stuff
but yeah sure yo dallas man salute the
lord dallas in the bill he's in the bill
let me tell you man he stepped up to the
plate
11th hour he got the vision you know
what i'm saying
pretty much we gave him not much to go
with let's be honest
and he nailed what we were trying to do
salute to him man
we're going to be working with you more
in the future brother got you slew fame
you know floor hugger the whole team
because y'all y'all really put it down
and y'all was definitely instrumental in
helping us with that
but uh yeah so uh that's the new j you
know i got more stuff planned
shout out to delilah yes hd
she gave us a lot of positive feedback
over the years and also never gonna
we're gonna have to have her her back
yeah i also never want to forget we also
want to shout out graphic card he's
still rocking still rolling you know
what i'm saying that's family ain't
nothing
i'm saying i spoke to the brother it's
all good you know
what i mean
yeah yeah yeah five dollar super chat
shout out to the 1pm start time thank
goodness
that's all you care about thank you
thank you about it could sleep obviously
but then after that we have hustling the
motorway with the financial attack was
that
dallas my god let's get it
dallas up dallas got that heat i'm
trying to put that boy trying to get
that boy worker
yeah no doubt then we got family went
away dragons tv to two dollars to attack
keep up the great work facts thank you
sir yo
all right so also i wanted to say one
thing yeah
we are like the lannisters mm-hmm oh
yeah we pay that we pay our next
you know we owe no debts um and we don't
ever ask for charity when i tell you
the word is out and i need you to step
up that's called a paid gig that's
actually allowing you to put some lights
on in that house if you're sitting in
the dark spitting in the bathroom
with the lights off the stomach and
you're hungry
i'm gonna give it right to you i just
gotta shout out two people blackroller
he said
i need that midsummer intro remix with
freddy gibbs and betty the butcher
he said can we get a country remix for
the midwest folk
i love it all right not again all right
so we're gonna go ahead and give one of
these codes away to the members only
right now i'll be throwing up the
patreon ones later on today
probably right after the podcast i'll
throw up the patreon questions
but here's the question out of all the
lords who has won
the most crown your lords that is our
been the need for the vgas
who has won the most but that the first
member to come up with that in the chat
we'll get one
oh let's go let's go get that up in
there let's see this yeah we got jd
gaming with the five dollar super chat
love how the lords are bringing in the
new year happy new year lords and may
this year be better than the last thank
you
sex we got a winner
who's the first it's stitch
nah thank you yo christopher i love the
fact that you put king
uh david i love the fact that
you love that you love the unfeeling
loyalty
king king he had to share his crown
it's like kobe bryant and shaq that year
that year that they both won so
it's me and attic is the winners of
sovereign has been the undisputed
heavyweight champion at this time
for his first first time he didn't do it
it's so good they're throwing him how
are you gonna take his moment
yo good night we had to jump in this
year this year i'm going to be like
whatever king says
[Laughter]
hey man well i think i said that a
couple of times
you know what's crazy the ones that i
said whatever saul says the ones that uh
you lost i'm glad you followed him
yeah but i want to give a shout out to
that dude that watched the intro
and put the dislike thank you
hit me up on twitter man hit me up on
twitter he said oh snap i won
[Laughter]
you wanna jump the uh new year off with
some
giving more giving back to you do it
correctly as we always do the start of
every month you know we give back to our
patreon and youtube subscribers and
and as king was saying and the rest of
the pod guys were saying
this is not possible without you guys
everything everything that we get comes
back to you guys in some way shape or
form so
thank you we really appreciate it let's
get into these giveaways for january
um i think i got to everybody so far i
think i've gotten to everybody
everybody's taken care
of that's actually gotten back to me
there might be one or two stragglers out
there that just don't have any
information but
if you happen to be listening and that's
and it's you get at me
in dm's and i'll take it um so let's do
this ten dollar
gift card giveaway and the winner
is
[Music]
cameron turner okay
no doubt ten dollar gift card giveaway
i'll get at you and dms i'll get at you
in the uh and
at your email address no doubt um
[Music]
a 20 gift card giveaway and the winner
of the twenty dollar
gift card is
albino dread
yeah thank you sir
let's get on to that t-spring drip
let's go i see what's going to be
icy of our teespring giveaway
regulator 951 hasn't won in quite some
time
regulated congratulations to all the
winners as we said thank you so much you
guys for your support this is our way of
giving back
um get at me in the dms if you hey if uh
if you're listening right now and you
know you won or i'll try to get back to
you later on today
no doubt no doubt people all caught up
there oh i'm sorry
because sir what do i say we haven't
used to be tattooed on that super chat
yep subscribe in our buildings
so we have fastback right we have
fastback of the two dollars super chat
happy new year iron lords thank you sir
likewise to you brother
anybody else no okay okay so we all
caught up all right
so that is good the realm and the
lannisters have paid their debts off
[Laughter]
but you know it's that time y'all it's
that time you know we got to talk about
that log that that lawrencygaming.net
you know what i'm saying it's always a
special special time and um yeah man
look
tremendous year we had long lane on that
our final episode and we went to
celebrate all the writers all the team
and uh we actually do this thing like as
you know you know say every month is
subscriber the month
and um this year actually right now
we're doing something a little different
in reference to
um just recognizing
the talent for the month but also also
another special award too so um
gotta give a shout out i don't know if
he could make it in time but my brother
um jt man of the book of jt hopefully he
could he could pull up because um
he definitely killed it this year man he
had a phenomenal
phenomenal year um tremendous articles
i mean you name it the guy was killing
playstation
his walk dudes was tremendous so uh yeah
salute him
that would be first jake thompson man so
scribe of the month
jay thompson he was on last week he also
writes for playstation brush
and everything oh somebody joined around
i just hear that so let me know about
that
mike yeah somebody joined the realm
really quick at the time i don't
see it i heard that cedric h okay okay
okay oh there you go
give a shout out to said cedric h
welcome to the wrong put the crust in
the chat y'all
put the questions i'm sorry then we have
one away dragons with the five dollar
super chat the new look is the sheesh
so good to see my brothers growing and
being humble is always doing what they
love salute thank you brother
absolutely man and if uh you've been
following 108 dragons go over there he
has a new look as well
yes stuff is looking really good and
crisp
over there on his channel and he's
giving you those gaming facts
right so yeah man sort of doing away but
yeah like i said so again scribe of the
month
new kid on the scene my boy jay thompson
the book of jt
tremendous articles on long neck killed
it last month some great cyberpunk
information
some great playstation information
walkthroughs and all that so salute to
him
and of course we have who has now pulled
up in the realm
the new winner yoda said of
the scribe of the year the culmination
of all the months and just voted in by
his peers someone who has been
tremendous to the iron law podcast
movement to the laws of gaming.net
movement
the work ethic is impeccable the
professionalism
you know everything he does is just been
super
quality work it's an absolute pleasure
you've seen this face many months
of subscribing above and now he gets to
culminate it
into the scribe of the year lord jeans
get that speech popping sir how am i
supposed to follow up that new intro
how can i follow that out that was
awesome i really liked that i was really
good
thank you thank you thank you so much i
really appreciate you guys uh
you know it's so weird i was thinking
about it this morning like what was i
going to say
and and i just want to say that i have
no idea nobody can really predict like
what this year is going to
uh give us or take away from us or what
kind of situations we're going to be in
and
we don't know if we're going to be going
to conventions or not but
we just know that we're going to be
successful no matter what we do and i
think that's weird we don't even know
what we're going to do but we know we're
going to be successful it's a great
group of people
that want to come and work really hard
and that are just passionate about games
you can talk about games all day
and i just i feel like something great
is coming no matter what
it happens i agree brother again been a
pleasure working with you a bit of
pleasure working physically with you at
conventions
it was just a treat to do that and like
i said i mean voted by your peers
as well as fierce competitions because i
want to salute the whole team
because sometimes when gene wins out he
ekes out some bumps and then sometimes
he doesn't doubt normal genes but you
know i want us to allow some people also
a person i never get a chance to shout
out to
that i always forget i look after the
show i want to shout out lord gondor's
condor aka
daniel may he is another tremendous
contributor
to the log that movement i always forget
so forgive me brother
i supposed to shout you out last show
because you've been another one like
mods gaming who's been there for the
very beginning shout out to lord jericho
silas
another one david urian we've got a
tremendous team this
these things i know y'all see jean a lot
but if he feels competition
i just want to state that i just gotta
state that you know
yeah gene is like mayweather yeah yeah
dedication and i'm gonna tell you right
now that that that consistency and that
dedication and that hard work definitely
pays off because
the boy goes in the gym like it's his
first time every time
and last but not least playstation
nation man please
please check out he has this tremendous
editorial that he does every month it's
called circle cross square
it is kind of like a state of
playstation kind of a bit
you know one of the early discoverers of
four guys
to to buy to spay because i was like why
is he always covering this game at facts
and this game ends up to be a sensation
so he's got his his finger on the pulse
of gaming
very very cool he's on again always
available again lord thank you so much
brother
reach out to myself dizzy because jt
also reached out to us because you got a
reward coming
and you sir either have a custom
controller and some other
cool little for the scribe of the year
rewards those are different that's a
different level to this
so hit us up awesome thank you um and i
just want to say you you know you post a
lot about
people joining the team and if anyone's
on the fence about joining or
thinks that they might have time to
write about video games during the week
reach out to me and dm me and see if
it's something you might want to get
into and i can give you advice and then
you can talk to them
just if you're on the fence you know and
you just want to bounce some ideas off
of some somebody or
what does it take uh 37 gene 37 on
twitter
uh or you can check cogs twitter feed
i'm probably on there a bunch of times
and
if you just want to bounce some ideas
off of me if you're looking to dabble
i'll help you out with whatever
information you might need
absolutely man thanks again brother
happy new year enjoy your day
with that drip gene yeah that gold is
looking kind of shimmery baby
absolutely have a good one brother see
you guys thank you bro
all right please man so we are all
caught up i believe with the business
let me just fix we have uh please please
calvin booth with the five dollar super
chat thank you brother for the for the
super chat you can say anything you want
um
some people are having issues with super
chats in the uh in the chat i think tony
bryant mentioned the super tattoo a
little broken
i still didn't see the last and uh
who's the last person that entered the
realm yeah
all right so we are we all caught up
with despite the uh crazy
yeah i think so i hope so no doubt man
if if you did a super chat and you don't
we don't see it pop
up or whatever um just just you know
yeah also hit up hit up uh solve and add
it directly
in the um you know what you call it in
the uh in the chat
so we will we call out that super chat
if we basically
definitely i'll bring up the screen
bring up the screen yeah just because we
can't miss anybody around these are the
guys
and ladies that feed us you know what
i'm saying give us love
we got one more face we got we got face
23 with the five dollars to be attacked
sony releasing an onslaught of games in
2021 to kick xbox while they're back
down what the hell are you talking about
all the way up like the only people
that's down is to do this denying that
they got dlc
dlc this is why i love this is why
y'all seen the faces on the main
character they got craig face
their nice bodies with craig's face
in the gym but they're not doing the
exfoliation of the skin
literally all of them is like this
they fighting the monster they're like i
can't you guys
their body is beautiful that's right
they work out in the gym but
they're not exfoliating and moisturizing
the face
that's why that's why i wear a helmet
cover your face anyway
we got tony ryan with the five dollar
super jet hashtag feed the wolves
so look man we got to get into it so um
was it no
poll last year so we do a new poll at
the end of the show oh wow hold on we
got to get
that's what bad brother one bad mother
shout out
we were on brad together uh early in the
week shout out to one bad mother with
the five dollars to attack
so you're trying to tell me level 10
isn't good enough to join you for a raid
happy new year
what look one bad brother like what you
witnessed yesterday has to stay in the
world
listen man what was funny is we like we
about to start the race we wouldn't be
able for joy i'm like who is this level
10
yeah like why is this put him here to
eat
so he must have accepted the xbox live
party invite when you set it to the
party
so he's like all right i'm jumping in
he's in the last section of the raid
the
the thing i remember is like that i
can't even talk
you look crazy right now we gotta get
your lighting up his bed
his bed is taking over his body
it's like his beard is a symbiote
like the darkness is
it might get a little bit loud just a
little bit but i'm gonna have to open my
door to get that light in there well you
work out what you gotta work out sir
um
[Laughter]
you but it's okay that can't read that
one okay gotta read that one yeah
blaze with the 50 you're putting it in
the crimson
stop at demon souls is 10 out of 10 king
we got a half that talk though
all right is that better is that better
out of 10 on playstation 3. okay
is that better yes and in this
generation
yeah we'll have to i'm going to have to
shut that down we are not going to be uh
giving up old verses and putting new are
you saying that's an
old verse so it's an old verse with a
new beat we gotta put that to the
garbage baby
see like i have to uh in order to get
this light and i have to open my door so
it might get a little loud on my mic
but you look good
literally anything in the living room
you guys are going to hear
nobody running to be like everybody
anyway
yeah there we have uh the living flame
with the five dollar super chat happy
new years lords hope you all had a great
holiday started my new year playing
dragon quest 11 and i regret nothing
excited for the medium though yeah
mediums in a couple of weeks yeah i'm
playing dragon quest 11-2 sir
yeah i'll see i'll see you in two years
when you finish that game
108 dragons with the five-dollar chat
i'm sorry godfall is being traded like
it was bought at the sanford and son
junkyard
i'm mad i bought it it's digital
although all special effects showcase
wow
i've heard this it's super pretty and no
depth
yeah i heard i heard this coming the
game pass see when it's free
[Laughter]
i wouldn't be surprised if that game
does come to game passes but it's coming
let's go that's fine
it makes sense no no i'm talking about
coming to x to game pass like king is
yeah i'm not like here you think it's
going to automatically show up in game
pad
i'm not buying anything no more anyway
so look we got to move on no paul will
be a new poll but we got
to get into these topics man king is
going to set it
off actually frame it from all ubisoft
plus y'all you'd be soft plus man a lot
of stuff going on a lot of
rumors about the ubs you put you beast
off i said the ups the uk
plus subscription service um yeah man
the rumors are it might be
offered as a part of microsoft's game
pass so um
shout out to good friend of the realm
windows central on chance cordon
with this information and again it's a
rumor for now but
he's he feels pretty good about it and
uh yeah he's pretty much saying that
he's saying there's a strong chance from
basil stuff he's heard
that reportedly states that ubisoft will
join the service in late
2021 and thinking about maybe the game
pass
ultimate experience similar to i guess
what uh ea play may have done
so um yes get this kids topic man i know
you brought this to the round you know
what's
you know what's crazy like i i didn't i
heard about this a couple days ago like
a week ago
but i was like man this is you nah
like i didn't even make a video about it
and then um
and then when when i saw you that's how
much i respect chad
like because i saw him tweet i was like
yeah let's make a video
[Laughter]
well king man you're the first to bring
it to the to the realm man
what you feeling what's going on first i
want to get uh blaze 4k that's my dude
five dollar super chat i'm going to bed
god bless brother get your
rest uh we'll we'll be here you catch
the show at the end and also just hit me
up uh
not on discord don't hit me up on this
oh my god
i told you guys a long time ago that i
felt that uh
ubisoft was going to uh find its way
into game pass
and um once i saw stadia fall by the
wayside because they
they threw they latin with stadia very
early on
right so you know i guess google came
with that bag and was like getting the
bushes with us
and and you know they stayed in the
bushes with that stadia
and stadia didn't get out the bushes
right now so i'm i'm happy
i'm not happy that stadia failed but i'm
happy
that it didn't uh reach the numbers that
they wanted it to reach so
that ubisoft could look at other viable
options and being that you know
game pass is the market leader in
streaming and downloading
uh digital games and stuff uh i think
this service will definitely benefit
ubisoft
and i said it before you know phil
dominance maximus aurelia spencer
is on a world tour like muhammad
he definitely is looking for good and
great content
to bring into the service and i was i
wanted to ask everybody in the realm
how did they feel when they heard the
rumor and
what was they and what were you
anticipating and playing because there's
a lot of games in ubisoft
that when i look back at the catalog i
said if
if that becomes available inside game
pass i think that's a
bigger acquisition than the ea access
to be honest with you um solver addict
want to set off
it yeah i've always said that when it
comes to
you know ubisoft games i feel like they
make more sense
than bethesda games like i myself
would gravitate more towards bethesda
games right right
all right now look at all the light like
i can't help it i can't hold it you look
fast you look good you're not like like
what's funny is like there's only light
on one side of my head because that's
where the light is coming from move on
sir
but you know that is one of the the
things like
i myself will drift more towards
bethesda games because that's the type
of games i grew up with but
i always felt like ubisoft is
that's that's that's the best type of
games that microsoft can buy
because i i do feel like their games
is the definition of games as a service
like like you can't get any better than
having like
games like rainbow six siege always on
your servers games like
for honor always on your service games
like um
that new uh the immortals game always on
your service like
like those are we ain't talking about
them
we act like that was a part of the
academy
i literally forgot i forgot the division
and so you know i think this would be a
good move do i think it's true i think
there's some kind of
uh you know because obviously when it
comes to
you know stuff like this especially even
stuff with like you know jazz chord
they're only toast stuff that that is
happening at the time
you know i know for a fact that people
has been told stuff that's changed
like the directions change yes so uh but
you know justcorn is usually on point
you know
obviously you know jazz gordon uh rand
dillard don't get
everything 100 right but but but they
they pretty good if i wanted someone to
go up to bat to hit that
to hit that home run it's going to be
one of them because chances are i'm
hitting the home run
nine times out of ten salute i agree i
agree
i didn't agree with you what you're
saying lord what's going on man
what you feeling about ubisoft i
remember in our private chat
when the ea play deal went through and
the
i was like this is this this is what
needed to happen to this and then king
of media was like watch ub solve his
neck
yeah caleb's on it oh he goes next and
i'm like yeah you're right
um because the thing about it is all of
these
all of these publishers tried to do
their thing with their own sort of
launcher right they all try to have
their own
storefront specifically for their games
and
it didn't work either because or it
hasn't worked either because
this their individual services are too
expensive
um and people are not the the perks
you're getting for actually getting the
game through them
aren't anything that's going to take you
away from actually buying it on the
playstation 4 or buying it on the xbox
store or even steam
so it's never it's never been that thing
where it's like i have to buy it from
them because i get such a great deal or
anything like that
so this this is perfect because you have
in them
if they were to come and get into bed
with it with game pads
you have what is objectively the
again the best deal in gaming continuing
to get better
and you're you know the amount of people
that have game passes growing
constantly so now you have your games
available and accessible to in excess of
15 million people
right um in a way where your back
catalog
is going to be available to all these
people and people again
it's it's not always about useful games
are huge but not everybody plays them
right
and just like anything else it's giving
accessibility
and to to games that other people may
not know about
because it's on that on that platform
and on that service
so i don't know what kind of deal it
would be obviously because
attic was talking about something that
felt like like imagine like day and date
or something like that that would be
bonkers right right
um i don't know that that would happen
that would be well i i i
wasn't meaning day and day because like
they just
i'm talking about their existing library
okay yeah because just like like just
like with ea
i just i just brought up the uh the
immortals thing because
that's an existing game but ubisoft's
titles
i don't i don't expect them to not being
gay past
too long after they launched after they
launched like i would say six months to
a year it's in game pass
yo one would think like you know what
this you think microsoft's like
strong-arming these people it's like
look
we got game pass we don't need your wax
service no
it's just everything it feels like part
of me feels like
like they're using game pass as a as a
leverage like look like
you guys maybe they approached them to
bring
their own version what was that premium
service thing on
um that's on pc and it's like
microsoft's like well you know
we we we're not gonna let that happen
but we can do this but that's the thing
like
if if if game pads weren't as successful
as it is they couldn't do they couldn't
show them
right so if they are strong on them
they're doing it with a smile on their
face like well you know
you know you could come here over here
and also let's just be
real right i mean for you for them to
even consider
their numbers can't be that great on
their own services right
and they're not yeah they're not they're
absolutely not that's the thing
for they anybody who goes to their
service
they're not getting any sort of premium
experience out of it any any period
any pricing right and you know the 10 is
whatever and you're still getting that
10
with with ea on on xbox right so what's
to say whatever discount you might get
getting something to the ubisoft or
whatever ubisoft launcher that they have
right um wouldn't translate to the to
the gamepad so
to me it's it's a win-win if it happens
it and if it does happen
then you start really seeing the
machinations of what game pass
is supposed to be facts
it's gonna be a if this happens it's
gonna be a huge
year for game pass it's gonna happen
earlier than later
you think so i would agree so too um
there's no reason for it not to that's
there's no reason for it not to
oh shout out to andy shout out to andy
crowley
first of all you make sure that our
notifications on anybody on the team
store works on the new
overlay so salute to you for that but
number two yo you got that
new mug you know what i'm saying oh
much appreciated for the merchant around
get your shout out
live you don't say it's anybody want to
cop that mercy as you can see we have it
set up we get your shout out live
and with your cops so salute to you
beautiful nice beautiful day bro thank
you let's get that fast back real quick
yeah we got actually two uh we got black
ronin
with the five super chat xbox game pass
series x series s
right through award two yeah it does
feel like it is
true yes that's right then we have
fastback with the five dollar super chat
king was right about tcl mine was
knocked out
by that serious x premium like paul did
robinson
oh in the bushes oh yeah i need to stop
that yo
a couple of days ago i just calibrated
my friend's series 6 tcl
[Music]
look good yeah not good once they were
once they got the government monitoring
i didn't say china wasn't watching them
i just said the picture looked good
it looked fantastic so they could see
you better i went over there you know
you know i went over there i did my
thing i have my spears and monster you
know i was out [ __ ] them
yo looking good okay 75 inch
mounted on the wall salute to them
shout out to that tco when you went over
there did he
[Laughter]
because you know how tv boxes aren't
huge anymore right they don't have
nuggets like that anymore but he had his
delivered
and this thing was half the size of his
hallway like it was
kids want to make sure they want to make
sure all the um monitoring uh
components that's in it don't let kids
slap you don't let kickstarter your tcl
personality
you can't
the police
oh no we have the living flame when you
when
when you play against added i expect
smitty sniff to add a whole new chapter
to the book of x the book of kings
the prophecies are ridiculous i do
appreciate it no
no but yeah so your friend jackson's
going to jump in yeah yeah we're good
we're good
with you with your thoughts oh yeah i'm
done man i just i i think if this
happens like i said
we're really going to start see what the
master plan starting to see what the
master plan what game pass is
yeah man i'm with you i think uh king is
definitely on
to something what's up you know it's
crazy it's not a coincidence that that
uh
that pc version of game pass was delayed
i don't think that was
i don't think that was on accident yeah
i think they deliberately delayed that
yeah look man i'm way i'm with um soft
here and king in
the sense that i if it does happen i do
think probably sooner than later um
one of the things that i like and i got
gotta shout out kings i love this i
gotta shout out phil down this maximus
spencer
oh really it's really really really
really good please don't forget the gold
forgetting the laurels yes i forgot all
his
his illustrious titles
i was very hard on them for the halo
infinite situation
you know as far as not having things
ready if that wasn't ready
right and the thing i said is i said you
got to do some short-term moves you got
to do some long-term moves right
short-term move just like a band-aid
stop the bleeding as far as an immediate
something you know getting people to put
their games
on released on the same day system
getting ea to sign the deal or whatever
it was
right around the boast of the lineup the
long-term move which was phenomenal
was the bethesda the xenomax excuse me
right so
now we come into 2021 we know the
climate now we know
halo infinite now is definitely full
so we've got this gap now medium's at
the top that's cool
but we've got this thing between medium
and then we still we still they may be
surprised we may not know but
in the meantime if you can continue to
bolster game pass with a
with a move like this and i think
ubisoft is perfect you know ubisoft is
even more
you know impressive than the ea thing in
my in my opinion you know
that's what i was saying yeah i'm with
you addict that this is the move because
from the single player standpoint what
you got the immortal phoenix you got
assassin's creed by itself
by itself by itself and we're just
talking about the games they're famous
for they make the south park games
they make steep yes like they they make
a lot of games and maybe maybe
you don't like all of them right but
they're one of those things where i feel
like they have a way more diverse
library than eve
absolutely and the thing about it i know
you know the iron lords we're destiny
focused but
and i know we cry except for me
in solidarity i'm not i'm that
assassin's creed guys
ever think about we yeah saul's just at
the gates of destiny we won't let him in
that's why
always tries to get into the destiny
community on my watch and i always shut
the door
anyway like i was saying you wish that
was true shut up
right but um yeah like to me even though
i know we always we kind of tease
division or sometimes here because we're
destiny fans
but the reality is you look at something
like division you look at something like
ghost recon
right now and rainbow six these you know
this
online service that fits so perfectly
into the xbox game pass infrastructure
you know that
engagement and look at what destiny is
doing right now
what i'm saying so many people are
playing like yo it's i got it
what the hell now you package that 60
frames per second upgrade next gen
upgrade 120 frame frame
your fps um competitive modes now you're
bolstering
your lineup to your competitor that yes
they can get it on playstation get it
somewhere else
but if you come over here it's 3.99 so
to speak right
it's 3.99 all these titles for that is a
huge deal
i think you know jess is pretty pretty
solid you know what i'm saying i i
definitely think this is something i
could see happening
game pass continues i got to start off
with gameplay
it continues to be by far the best
service and
dealing it's not even close in my
opinion now it's not even close like
when you have an ea you have potentially
a ubisoft
then we know big cinemax is coming you
know what i'm saying
all these in there now the question is
going to be
i agree with you so i don't think
ubisoft will be day and date
i think ubisoft will put like last
year's what's last year's assassin's
creed
yeah last year's would be uh odyssey
odyssey right
and then you'll probably they'll
probably do this the year before
yeah they'll probably do the easter eggs
i mean
the last one right so i mean but by the
time they say it does take a couple it
happens in a couple of months down the
road
right i could easily see valhalla being
in there six months ago
easily and the thing is you would that
sixth above when once the physical stale
start to drop
right and and everybody it's saturated
then you could
and they got up they got a big light up
hold on let me let me know that to be
honest with you it's
um more about engagement right of course
because the the more
and this is for more for ubisoft
because ubisoft has a lot of that loot
purchasing
and customization purchasing and uh
trying to get you to do a lot of
background purchasing
in odyssey itself i purchased the game
with odyssey i brought the season pass
and all that stuff from odyssey
but then again i was going back and
forth buying little things to make my
horses
and bows and all this other stuff look
good so
if you start to take that into factor
right because physical sales once your
physical sales drop off after the first
month because all the fomo dudes already
i already got it right
facts so the fomo dudes got it within
the first month and then they're on to
the next really to be honest with you
and then once the game starts to mature
nobody is really going to look for it
except for those consistent
dedicated people right now the fact that
you have some upwards of uh
20 million people inside game pass at
any given time
you have those people inside game pass
that's an eye opener facts
to any one of these uh companies that
did a service or are doing a service and
it's not getting those numbers that game
pass is garnering
right and the fact that ubisoft looks
over there because they expected google
because google has worldwide reach
to reach these individuals it didn't
happen that way with stadia
so they look over at game pass and they
see ea now i'm pretty sure ea shares the
numbers with them like yo this is what
we're doing in engagement numbers
because my son right now no no cap and
as i was coming downstairs i'm like what
are you playing
oh jedi falling in order so he's playing
jedi fallen order and that game came out
a minute ago
but this is engagement numbers now it's
not
new game but it's a new game for him
right right
so okay i was just gonna tell them real
quick while you're talking
uh um give me privilege to share my
screen
okay i i have the their list on their
website up of all their games
okay and so now that you got uh
these games that would be potentially
released inside game pass
the more that the individuals interact
with said games that have
customization and little things like
that in it the likelihood of those
purchases
tripling and quadrupling goes up
immensely because the game is being seen
by
other eyes that normally they would not
see it
right so now these games like
prince of persia uh rainbow six siege
and all these other games that see i
wouldn't purchase ubisoft
uh play separately separate but if it's
free it's free 99 like cod said in game
pass
i'm going to partake in a ghost recon
absolutely we're going to partake in
these games so can you on fire because
at the end of the day
once you're in these services you're the
propensity
to spend money on something now that
you're in because you don't even feel
the obligation that you paid anything
you're already in there
so now if you're having fun okay i don't
feel bad if i spend two dollars for this
skin or whatever this dlc or whatever it
is
and that's part of the hook and like i
said yeah that also think you made a
good point is let's be real we don't
have the metrics on how they're doing
on their own remember
and if you look at this i didn't realize
all this because this is stuff they
published too
i forgot like they do the far cry games
they do the uh the talk
the rainbow six they do the the watchdog
series
if you look down here they they're doing
like the party games too
the just dance the south park games uh
skull and bones whatever the hell that's
going to come up
yeah beyond good and evil too another
game
these games fit perfectly they do all of
the um
battleships scramble monopoly rush
another thing that we haven't touched on
is that they recently
announced that one of their games moving
forward
support cross save finals yes
so that's if that moves if if this move
happens and it moves to game pass with
that crosstalk
that is another reason for people to be
like well i might as well just get it on
game pass because i can play anywhere if
i don't want to necessarily play it
through
i can still so it just feels like
this is a move that can allow game pass
to sort of extend its tentacles
like in a way that kind of quietly
doing it and also the thing is this too
so if you forget they were
very aggressive early with cloud
themselves
right that interest them so now again if
their metrics are showing that for
whatever reason
they're not doing as good as their own
and oh yeah they're just the game pass
they're seeing the game pass engagement
and the x cloud engagement
now you put those on additional screens
that you yourself would have never had
that reach to
after like what king is saying after the
this is a great if it happens this is
it's been
a phenomenal deal for both and
additionally to that so all that stuff
we just talked about right the fact that
there is a partnership there same with
ea yes
that could mean specific uh uh sort of
uh exclusive stuff for xbox down the
line whether it be
again like would it would have a they
need to make that franchise like
splinter cell
it's been dormant you know that that
game that game is essentially
a microsoft game like if you think about
you know the history of that game and
how it started especially the first
three games like
that's an xbox game like it's seen as an
xbox game i i
i understand what you're saying but if
if it gets inside game pass see but this
this is how i view games like that
right the the niche crowd could be
screaming for it but we're
they're looking at the casual fantasy
casual fan gonna screen for it as well
right
so you say you get ubisoft there inside
game pass now microsoft can look at the
metrics off of that game engagement
like see if everybody's going back to
play blacklist if anybody's going back
to play spies versus
mercs you understand and to see what the
level of engagement is and see if it's
interest to fund a game of that nature
exactly right but the thing is remember
how we talked about how do we get big
third parties onto game
pads right how does that begin to happen
this is how it begins to happen
this is how it begins to happen before
you know that
when they go like if you think about it
like you know i didn't even think about
that kind of perspective of
like the information that microsoft
would have like oh
right now all they have is the
information off the stuff that they
currently have
yeah off their games but if they start
having access to stuff like ubisoft
like their numbers well you know this
game's only doing this much on game pass
i know your
numbers ain't that hard it's like it's
like it gives them a little bit more of
a room it's like all right since we know
we both know
this game doesn't do the greatest like
what what's it going to take
for a day one on is it the fact that
right now it's like division yeah the
work
you say you say the two leading games
that they put and division didn't have
an upgraded pack chat
yep think about launching day and date
similar to destiny did
with new content next gen xbox series
exodus
optimization and then boom right in the
game pass
on launch date that's it because it's
funny they're two they're two leading
games
it's funny what their two leading games
are because one is assassin's creed
right
the other one is just dance yes and the
other one's just dead
like it yo yo yeah it could be fine
it would be a bigger move
in in terms of forcing
gamers over that would
push the s the s not the x
harder to to the secondary console
oh yeah all right because listen let's
let's let's keep it a buck
playstation or sony people is going to
gravitate towards sony regardless of
what they were sitting there
right holding hands waiting for a game
to come out every two years
or whatever you know and engage in
whatever they can get engaged in and
act like playstation now isn't doing any
numbers or
act like oh we got the collection we
down here playing a bunch of old games
in high-res
um and they feel like they're they're
winning mm-hmm
the when you have to force them to bend
the knee because you know
they like well those bethesda games is
going to take a long time
you know and i don't really play madden
like that anyway so that ea don't matter
now when you brought valhalla day one
because you wanted to see it on your
playstation
or you brought uh watchdogs because you
wanted to see it on your playstation and
those games are available in game pass
and it's making your pockets look like
sour grapes and you got
ubisoft over there you might have to say
you know what
let me just partake in that just to get
those games that i love
over there and i can wait for the sony
bangers the triple a bangers to come out
every two or three years that when they
do drop them
and i can be over there to play that but
you can't deny
at that point microsoft's a game pass
will be a one-stop shop
right for gaming services as a fan
as a fan i'll say this as a fan of
looter shooters
right i feel that gamers yeah they
already have destiny they got that
think about it technically they got
anthem right mm-hmm with ea
right fix your face
i mean i mean just final fantasy 14 came
back so i don't listen
you never know again if those companies
respectfully
put in the next generation patches and
then launch day and date in a service
like that that is tremendous value
it's like king saying it's perfect for
those live service games those lunar
shooters
those mmos that keep in mind they've got
stuff like minecraft dungeons too yeah
so
let's let's get these super chats
game pass got me into d2 it's fire
playing right now
facts yeah a couple of days ago
and we got saying tomlin with the five
pound super chat happy new years lords
let's work on a year of getting rid of
the toxic fan boy small community god
bless the book of
thanks though then we got perfect shogun
with the five dollar super chat
happy new year 2020 and 21 uh bought to
bring about to bring the heat
can't wait for the medium hit that dual
reality like button yeah
medium is we'll talk about that in a
second
we all caught up yeah i think so yeah
man great
topic by the king we are going to move
on and
just some fun you know 2021 is a new
year new day
so long man
just you know studios man we got a lot
of
you know studios that either were
acquired or just on both sides of the
fence whether it be playstation xbox
nintendo whatever so just in general i
want three studios from the lords just
you don't have to narrow an hour to
three but you know what
801 any student that you're like most
excited
to hear from in 2021 so let's start with
man what studios
studio or studios that you're excited to
hear from what you most hype
about for twenty is does this have to be
realistic like
is it just i mean this is just your
heart man what you would think
from the first one's tech land with
dying light too mm-hmm
i it's not realistic but i'd like to
hear from playground about fable
um and i'd like to hear from obsidian
about a vowel
i feel that hey gotta shoot those are so
far unreal i would like to see to hear
some form of a splitter cell
announcement too that would be nice
let me get this super chat specifically
for my brother cat
daddy lurk cat danny 2021 is
you all's yes keep up the girl first of
all salute the cat
one of our one of the realest in the
realm two
everyone's saying they love cause the
young lord
cat is on the way should be today
so say your love you know what i'm
saying send some uh some positive vibes
lord cat lady cat
you know what i'm saying as they are
closed in on the future of the realm
you know what i'm saying so salute them
and then also on a side note please send
some love got to mention this earlier
sense of love to lord jay fonzarelli
he's got some stuff going on right now
on a personal level
he can use some positive vibes that is
another family to the realm
so again soon to these two brothers they
always show love to us
we gotta show some love back so i'm
gonna get the rest of these super chats
yes we got we got stitch with the two
dollars we chat game passes perks with
those final fantasy 7
demo
there we have the living play with the
two dollars i'd like to hear from
compulsion
and play stealing one of my eyes that's
what's up that's what's up you already
know so that's from addicts so soft man
who you want to hear from who you most
hyped from from a studio perspective
i'm actually i want to see some of these
smaller studios like really
come up with games that's supposed to be
launched in 2021 so for me
um on the sony side um it's ember labs
and the guy's making kenna
the kind of bridge of spirits that game
looks like a cartoon straight up
um and i'm excited to see if they can
actually get the game part right because
these guys these are guys that are used
to making
you know video and stuff in graphics for
movies and stuff like that
this is really their first game um and
it looks
like i said it looks like really well
for them yeah yeah
so i if they hit with this game this is
their coming out party so i'm excited
for that
um and on the xbox side like we just
mentioned a few minutes ago
bluebird team and that media they they
have the worst name in the business but
but i will say like you can see the
progression in terms of
uh kind of like the way they they do
horror right when you look at
uh layers of fear then you look at um uh
blair witch these are guys that i think
they're like moving forward they can be
a really special team in terms of what
they do
there were aspects of it i was so
excited for that game and they're
disappointed in something you know what
it disappointed me
in the frame rate yeah oh yeah play it
play it on pc
well hopefully it can get a i'm not
going to
you know what though i haven't
downloaded it again on the series x
could be fixed yeah maybe it might brute
force it
you know this this is what i don't like
but you know late i don't like if i put
a game on the x
and it don't yeah i'll be back yeah yeah
yeah
it's the same man we got a little bit
look at the developer
the only thing here is auto hdr that's
it
it looks it looks like shinier yeah yeah
i think they're the same frame pace
yes i think that's one of the things i'm
disappointed with them the most about
because i'm like
i'm like there's obviously some of these
games weren't ready but it's just like
man you could have had obsidian
like make a patch up for 60 frames
that's the developer like yeah but i've
said it
yeah that was that's weird that you know
first party title
that's what i'm saying it's perfect the
vibe by beginning with obsidian is they
still have the
contractual obligation with private
division to finish those two dlcs
on that old contract so that what might
be i don't want to give them a complete
package
yeah they that should have had a package
they better fix the way they do dlcs
because i'm really
i'm bored yeah
i feel for you right now i feel for that
one i gotta start the game over and i
gave him my money and i didn't want to
go back in there and say give me my
money back i feel i really didn't
i mean i'm just looking at it as a loss
because that's
very that that game took me a long time
you understand like and for me to go all
the way back yeah
yeah come on man not for you i feel that
was definitely
handled weirdly you know as far as the
savings yes there should always be a
point
where if you're going to say if you get
to the end of the game
you know that should be a bookmark and
then
it should be a separate tab for your dlc
like everybody else do it that's this
like whose man is this
what was this like i know i really see
y'all don't ever hear me going on xbox
live
right now that was pissed that way
do you know my face see they see they
got a chance to hear me
cry and moan when i thought i lost my
gun
in destiny yesterday yes they got a
chance to hear me go buck for that
because i was going to go in on destiny
today
um oh boy y'all would have heard some
stuff from me
but i found it and something weird
happened
but for me to go pay for it i think i
hit attic
up too i think i hit him up because i
think he's my go-to every time something
goes wrong
i'm like did this because i hit him up
the other day and i was like what is
that no time to explain
and then that's another deluxe edition
yeah and
i'm not getting it it literally it's the
only time i've ever felt like destiny's
a pay
to play a game and and it's the only
time i've ever be like man i should have
got the deluxe of this yeah i don't know
i only shout out the cat is in the chat
i only fought out about that issue
because of cat
he he's like what's that gun you got
where'd you get it and i'm like bro
that's part of the you know the dow
deluxe dude people telling me no you
just go talk to barracks no you don't
yeah yeah one of those
no i wouldn't no because i don't have it
and that's declared those law sectors
it's the best yeah it's ridiculous
do you want to get the super chancer can
you even upgrade it anymore
upgrade what yeah you could i think i
think i've been
14 no can you up like um
can you upgrade to because they you they
let you pay the bills upgrade to the
digital edition
we got bounty boom with the five dollar
super chat happy new year can anybody
tell me if jedi fallen order is getting
a next gen
update great show and also how do i get
into the destiny group
all right first uh question next gen
update is coming currently right now
jedi order is brute forcing 60. so
you're getting 60 but there's no
next gen optimization yet which by ea
they made an announcement in the blog
that it's coming they pulled it down but
it still come from what i heard
internally it's still coming
um as far as the clan hit me or king up
in the dms on twitter
you already know me at lorcan and
twitter and then you gotta hurry up
because um spots we're like at 100 close
to 100 again
so just add me and destiny if you're on
destiny
uh go to um king david otw add me
i'll see you then give me a message so i
know who you are so i'll add you and
then i add you to the client faction
david let me try to even get a raid day
today
we're going to don't add me on twitter
talking about king david farm i'm not
finding you
put your bungee dot name gamer tags in
there it's not about playing invite you
got to reach us
it's a private situation
we're gonna have to start that if you
ain't on in a month you're getting
kicked out yeah and we will we
will be doing attendance checks if
you're inactive for like couple months
sorry you gonna have the ass to get back
in this is that fluid situation
yeah definitely we need we need them
every day yeah we need
active people i need to be in the old
range
because it's hot this month then you
fall off
we monitor in attendance continue
yeah no no we got a couple of super
chats we have jd gaming with the 5
super chat tech land is coming to the
xbox family so is the sobo
and io interactive and dope nod yeah
yeah your mouth to god is yeah but i i
but i look forward to the next forza
horizon and killer instinct yeah could
no doubt no doubt we got one more uh we
got gotham guy with the five dollar
super chat
i heard compulsion games upcoming title
was a mixture of bioshock and uncharted
so that studio is definitely peaking my
interest that would be
yeah that would be be nice that'd be
nice yeah we gotta go see
we gotta ask nila what's going on let me
give a special shout out even though
it's not a color because it's my man
javier mccann salute i love my brothers
felice
ano nueve garcia v campbell good
fight go see a versus campbell good
fight so salute to him you know what i'm
saying
that's our brother that's for pr that's
prepping for yeah
i talked about it earlier so just go
back and then you'll hear fight talk
yeah you know it's a little javier for
pulling up man he likes the 1pm time he
said
whereby yeah i'm sure oh we caught up
there
yeah we're caught up all right cool who
felt this talk was it uh that was me i
just finished the last thing i said was
uh
the medium and three studios you
hype excited wanna hear from what
studios i wanna hear from naughty dog
i really i'm i'm really anticipating
you know where they're at with it and
what's what's going on with them mm-hmm
um who's the studio that does god of war
that's uh what you call a boy is from um
sony santa monica this is only santa
monica
i wanna hear the truth from santa monica
um i want to know if they're going to uh
shun the last generation shun that money
or are they going to do cross-gen and if
they're going to do cross-gen
is it going to be dlc or is it going to
be a complete
game i want to know truth um you know we
was held in the shadows you know for a
long time with
miles morales up until the last moment
and
i don't want that this time i want you
know just true transparency from that
aspect of it
uh to give more clarity when it comes to
that situation on that game
and it can quell a lot of anticipations
or a lot of expectations
for certain things you know just
seriously i agree because when
when uh and i just i just want to know
more
going forward especially with because
you already know
it's going to be god of war and what's
what it entails i want to know a little
bit more not the
plot and stuff like that or enemy types
and stuff like that i just want to know
the basic premise and aspect and length
of of the game is it going to be
comparable to god of war the one we just
got
uh in length and and in content or is it
going to be a scale back
smaller version of that to bridge us to
an actual
you know next-gen uh god of war
that's that's what i'm anticipating um
and the reason why i say naughty dog
is because naughty dog seems to me to
bring out the best
in sony products so i really want to see
because they really laid a groundwork
for what is potentially
uh could be done on a playstation
platform and i think the other studios
grab
assets from them and see how far they
can make their games because after a
naughty dog
game comes out uh the bigger better
games start to
you know grow in the distance and they
usually cap off the gin
with something uh utterly amazing
they're working on a sci-fi game
that that'd be fantastic i'm down for
that i'm looking for a definitely new ip
from them
yeah after they after they get out or
the multiplayer for
the last of us yeah when is that coming
i think that's
done i think they're just waiting for
the numbers of the playstation to
actually hit
that so they could be available before
they
dropped that that's correct yeah well
you know listen you know goldsmiths
we're not gonna do
the reason why i say that because dudes
would still think they just shut down
service on naughty dogs
you know so i'll be the best it has the
longevity it has
the the ability and the staying power we
don't know about ghosts
if we can stand oh see that see
the lotus blossoms
continue continue yeah but i'm and and
from microsoft
it's two studios that i'm looking
forward to and wanting to know more
the same way i say i want to hear more
transparency and stuff like that from
sony santa monica
yeah 343 with all the chaos that's going
on in the background
i want that k i don't want to hear that
noise
about who's making what who's in what
position that's not telling me about the
aspects of the game
i want to know more aspects of the game
i want to know
more aspects of halo infinite i want to
know the targets
i want to know how big and what content
we're looking at
i don't know how many hours we're
looking at engagement i want to know if
it's going to be a game for service
i want to know if it's going to be a
standalone complaint i mean real
transparency
when it comes to this game that has me
so fearful now
hopes yes turn 10.
um interesting when turn
10 gets a hold of any microsoft console
oh hardware watch yeah they get this
hardware
um forza 7 that's a freudian slip
forza 7 is by far
the best looking racing game and i know
you're going goofy dudes
you know grand tourism they did the
shine by shine
and they put 60 frames per second 4k
shut up go sit down in the bushes
don't talk to me about fidelity if
you're playing on a tcl
i do not want to hear you all right do
not
talk to me if your assets ain't in check
oh
there's a tv situation yeah they think
they'd be active they be fraudulent with
a 1440p
television live vrr yeah they have
nothing going on
flickering and stuff assets popping up
artifacts
but um i really want to see what turn 10
does
because i know given this hardware
because i look at that forza intro and
with the cars coming down and you see
the road and
people walk i'm like oh they're going to
kill it
and i know turn 10 they
make it their point to keep that
foot on grantin rizmo's
neck they didn't make it that point to
step on the throat
and don't give them no room to breathe
because i remember when gran turismo was
the undisputed king of racism i remember
that and
forza fought like hell to supp uh
surpass them
and supplant their foot inside the
racing genre
keep that foot on their neck and they
said for extra measure
we're going to give you horizon just in
case you want to have fun and driving
around
and you don't want to be no sims then we
we're going to control
every aspect of racing and take that
from you so i think
that that that that forza and i was
going to go
well turn 10 i'm so intrigued by
them i feel you yeah they definitely
they definitely push hardware man
shout out to james it was a chat but i
had to say he said king your tcl rants
are becoming industrial espionage
[Laughter]
did we get any super chat today no i
think we're good all right cool let me
jump in yeah man you guys got some good
choices oh for me
it is going to be the lords of respawn
what are they cooking you know am i
gonna get my titan for three
am i gonna get that announcement you
know why you got no
[Music]
um like i mean you can't ask a question
and i and i answer it
yeah but i'm going to agree with you
obsidian which is a hope and dream
to join as well they announced the bell
but my thing is this year if we're gonna
hear anything that's the question if
we're gonna hear anything else or
whatever about their lineup or whatever
so that's cool and my dark horse man
i know i've been on my my pulpit with
the hashtag just one y'all know
i'm gonna beat the drum to the end even
though xbox family xbox mafia is very
upset with me
you know saying how dare i ask 23
studios to make one third-party
cinematic game but my hope is
compulsion i i'm hoping
they've got the first part down third
person right now just neat narrative
cinematic driven i'm pulling for
compulsion to be the just one
even if it's just an announcement
trailer that i know is being worked on
cog will put his guns down it will be a
cease and desist slander
on the mafia but until then y'all
getting this work
for that one game that y'all acting like
i can't ask for
i think i think they're well now so
that's what i want yes i want i want
that type of game on xbox just one
so that's that um attic um we got to see
what's up with in exile man i know me
and you got to get busy i'm gonna hit
you up i don't think they'll announce
anything this year
i'm just curious you know being once
they finished you know wasteland threes
i don't know i think
contract here from that may be 2021 2020
i mean 2022
2023 right because their game literally
just started and it's supposed to
it's it's not it's not the waistline
type like it's a full-blown
rpg like but it's it's more on like
the outer worlds of valve scale than it
is on you know
just a turn-based strategy game yeah so
you know we're
just curious to see what once they're
free from wasteland
with the budget what they do and back to
combustion i want to say that the reason
why i'm even more excited
i will think they're coming out this
year yeah the reason why i'm most
talking about coach is because
every time they speak the film phil says
he's
super hyped about whatever they cook it
up like he always mentions compulsion so
i'm like
you know what i'm saying let's see
what's going on shout out to others
no xbox fan wants a movie game
yo he's so bad to ask for your others
make me ride him and die i don't want
that type of game
stop it you've got a diverse platform
they could be in game
but xbox makes those games it's just
they've made a new one
in a while that's all right so we got
that and then last thing i'm kind of
pulling a king move
on how he mentioned uh what you call it
with graphical fidelity as far as forza
i know we just got hive busters and i
know they're working on most likely gear
six but
yo coalition from a graphical fidelity
standpoint
as far as getting the power out of xbox
that have busters man that got me
excited
could you imagine them with a new ip and
it could be 80 ip they well it don't
have to be third person
i'm just saying i'm just curious with
them
what it could be if they made something
different forget just to see what else
you know what i'm saying they could do
that would be kind of fire so that's
where i'm at i think when they finish
gear six they're gonna make a new ip
because possibly
but you know what i like attic i like
that because of all the studio
acquisitions the pressure is not on
gears to come out so
fast i feel like this past generation
they kind of relied on gears
because they knew they didn't have you
know a lot of times
in halo you know it's it's easy for
people to tell them to make a new ip
yeah well that's the only eyepiece
bringing in money absolutely
absolutely now now that you got like you
got the uh i don't think this honor
it might come back but you got the elder
scrolls franchise
you got the doom franchise i mean you
still got halo because you know
halo's going to be around for a while
compulsion could step out on gears and
do something new because they
they they have more of a spotlight
that's not on gears anymore
right yeah it'll be interesting the last
thing for the sony side i already know
i'm team
team goals team sucker punch i'm curious
with second places
they surprised me man they really did i
i i didn't think they'd be
capable of a game like ghosts and that
they made me a true believer so
as far as their versatility in the
studio so i'm curious to see what they
got cooking next i think
it may be too early because you think
we'll see more raids from them
i'm down for that it is what it is man
let's get the super chat let's move on
so
uh we got fazel double o seven with the
five pound super attack what xbox
publishing big party third
third big third party exclusive game
deal are they going to have
i don't think they're going to exactly i
think i think microsoft's done with that
i don't think they're doing that anymore
yeah again it goes back to
this this sort of uh game pass thing and
you know i think i think one of the
the you know behind closed doors that
was one of the conditions that
xbox had to meet it's like look we'll
fund all these studios we'll fund making
this studio
but that third party exclusive's done
because you have all these studios
i think it doesn't you can't
split the pie like as far as the bag
goes
either you all in and you're not you
understand like chasing third-party
deals for exclusive content for a short
period of time
on a problem it's not even a band-aid
actually it's just sticking your whole
your finger inside the hole in the dam
because at some point in time you got to
pull your finger out because somebody
else
is uh going to get that content see it
doesn't make any sense
king they have so many studios that at
this point
they have a better chance of buying dead
franchises that
that the industry's forgotten about like
dead space etc etc
and just adding that to one of their
studios to rebrand then
making that studio make that game yes
exactly
i i understand exactly what you're
saying or or
actually pursuing some of these uh
what is it uh korean studios
that are putting out phenomenal uh
content
that we're seeing being made over there
i i
feel they should start
looking in those uh asian markets
to get those because i'm seeing a lot of
these mmo type of games that will
thrive inside game pass with the visual
fidelity
of next generation type graphics going
forward we saw a lot of these games
being talked about and i feel if if they
can grab these i don't care
who does it to be honest with you i
don't care if sony does it or microsoft
does it
but please start looking in these areas
to get these games
here i don't want these games to be
living over there
blocked off from us that we don't get a
chance to see these games after they
don't mature
and people have been playing it for
years and then we get it and we like
what
it's been a thing for three four years
no these these studios should be
highlighted and seen because they're
doing phenomenal work
uh because we saw some stuff and i'm
like
why aren't the big guys looking to
acquire these studios
or or to to purchase these games do
something in that nature because
it's too quiet when it comes to that
side of the world for us
when it comes to stuff like that like i
i feel you on that and like i guess it's
because like a lot of those games don't
really appeal to me
and it would be cool if they i i would
more go towards like the the japanese
oriented studios like i want more of
those in the first party lineup
uh but you know if i could wish one
thing microsoft would do
it's like i said i want some of these
games that i loved
that their publishers just stopped
supporting right and i i want them
redone
and it's like i've said from the start
it's like look i think the coalition
make a
a phenomenal army of two game and
and i think uh ninja theater would make
a one hell of a dead space guy
so listen i i love it man these are the
studios that i get is
it'll be cool you know to see again if
we get any more reveals or anything that
they're working on so those are the ones
i am the most hyped for in general we
are going to move
on i believe addict you are up
and we gotta uh one more time real quick
we got jd gamer with the five dollar
super attack give me quantum break two
and rise two and bring on sumo digital
to do rare classic
ip remakes like banjo or conker i could
see that i i think
i don't know i'm confident a banjo's in
process
uh yeah i don't know about a quantum
break i don't think that's very uh
i don't think that's happening and arise
i honestly think a rice 2 would be
amazing but
i don't think that's happening either so
let me see fix that last quantum break
and and you know what it is after
playing control i don't want to see
nothing else
i'm being honest with you just good stop
stop just stop don't worry you know just
stop unless you're gonna get picked up
by
uh the bag like i see what y'all do with
the bag i love what quantum break look
like
the bag was phenomenal but then you got
control without the bag
don't do nothing without the bag get the
bag first let a studio
fund you let somebody give you some
bread because i got the control aspect
down
y'all got to be honest with you i think
i think sony needs to buy
uh remedy i think they're the only
studio that can handle
whatever they're doing they do kind of
fit their wheelhouse
yeah i think that's the perfect studio
pick them up
i want microsoft to stay far away from
remedy well this is transitioning
this is transitioning perfectly to your
topic attic
since you're talking about who should be
buying what let's go right in man top
three studios like you said as far as or
just studios in general
that xbox and playstation should buy you
feel playstation should look at remedy
you feel xbox will stay far away i'ma
let you jump off with your old topic
yeah so you know considering there what
there's not a lot going on right now
because the new years i wanted to do a
fun topic
i wanted to do you know the lord's here
since i knew it was just going to be us4
i wanted to ask every lord what
three studios do you want uh microsoft
and sony to buy what studio you think
would make sense to it it doesn't really
have to make sense i guess like maybe
it's a studio that you think
that would remedy i know sony doesn't
have a lot of multiplayer stuff but i do
want it to be in the realm of
possibility
like i want you saying like activision
ubisoft
like i wanted to be in the realm of
possibility in the studio you think
would really
complement or you know add on to the
strengths currently so you know
you could you could go the week this one
like so microsoft doesn't have that
that that that store orientated you
could pick a game that really goes that
or you could go
you know microsoft needs more
multiplayer we're going to pop on this
one
uh i want to start with king first
because i'm curious what king got
himself okay
um for sony uh like like you said uh
remedy it fits well within their
uh single-player you know uh type of
thing and then
sony can sony can keep their quality
control on their neck
[Laughter]
are you implying that without the bag
the level of quality from revenue games
is out there
boy i would love to see how sony's
quality control
like they'd be like go back go back
we're going to let that cook until it's
done
because they don't allow something to
slide out
[Laughter]
positive sony stuff dude you know no i
trust me i really would love for that to
happen
so what what's your biggest beef with
control oh god please
no we're gonna get it again the story
the story
i mean because if if you're coming from
um quantum break and then you're going
over to control
quantum break and i know sincere sage is
gonna get at me i played it the other
day
oh they don't control as good as control
sorry that's just that
sage is going to write 10 tweets
on you now he could write a book or he
could do whatever tell the truth
i i i've touched both paws and
and i and i can tell the difference
right off the bat right off the bat
you know there's no limitations in how
you move and how you run and get away
from stuff inside control
and in quantum break it's more your the
control
holds you back from doing what you need
to do but then you know just story i
don't need to be reading books to find
out about the story i don't care about
that
you know paper i'm not reading no books
to find out what i need to do next
and and who kills bobby's baby
you know somebody said did you read the
book on the third floor around the back
end of
that i don't care about them
[Laughter]
he watched he watched the tv show tv
shows
listen the six hour the video twenty
years i watched the big pack the one
that you know
took up all your hard drives and i
watched story
i sat there and watched the whole story
when they were blowing up stuff and i
felt
like i was part of something that was
happening i'm part of nothing in control
yeah um yeah so i want them to buy a
remedy
um ready at dawn um
i i thought i thought it was like a sony
studio but to come to find out
it isn't they lose yeah so i think they
make really they make my type of games
you know choose your direction yeah that
little team what was the drink the team
killer joint that was like a friday
thirteenth back up kind of just
it was funny who going later who got
died i gave us one
until dawn right and yeah i actually
really really liked that game
no that wasn't there wasn't ready at
dawn that wasn't them
that was super massive all right so then
again
who who purchased supermassive no one
else
they got banned dynamical they're doing
the the dark pictures anthology
they embed with bandana namco okay those
aren't as good as uh
the other ones as yeah as until dawn
yeah but
yeah i i i like that that aspect of it
all right um and then what's another one
for sony
um sony sony
well they need multiplayer right and
yeah i i don't know what i always say
because people like
why don't you ask 70 to make multiplayer
you always asking
xbox to do xbox state sony stuff i
always complain that there's not enough
co-op and multiplayer games
first party by sony i always complain so
it's not one sided slant everybody
getting slander
from cognito well whatever studio that
is loose out there that is great at
multi yeah they need it bad
yeah i really think they they they
should look in that direction
they're made among us you know um
like whoever made among us i think they
should look at them
and and because the game is phenomenal
in that short brief
stance that i got a chance to play it
you know i can't wait for me and addict
to play it on the six me and attic is
going to
uh join on and we're gonna have a great
time on the six to play the game
so that that's my for sony um for
microsoft who do i want them to buy
[Music]
sony
i want sony to go out and purchase all
the stuff that i said and then i want
microsoft to come in and hostile
takeover
when i saw on twitter it said microsoft
purchased sony
oh yeah yeah i saw that that was funny i
was wondering yo
oh god in them on god
and this show
if is ever a day that that reality
happens
there's no containing you there's no
containing you
this show me should be fair i would have
did standing up with a headset i would
have brought a different headset
and i would have did standing up the
whole show
um you know how george foreman when
george foreman came back and he didn't
sit down
you know he's just standing in the
i know crawling like way that they would
announce that too like an e3 conference
or something like that
and and g.o.w comes up you think it's
god uh you think
here's a war then god of war comes up no
no
i wouldn't even want it to be like that
i don't want phil
dominus maximus are really expensive to
walk out
on just a regular tweet just a regular
tweet
walk out with the microsoft you know uh
the black screen and just walk out he
just come out
from behind the gate said uh fight's
over
fights oh yeah pick your mans up
the fight's over the kick list of
monopoly king
yes that's not what equal competition
i don't know i don't care about
competition you don't care about
nothing spicy water get him up out of
here
he's gonna be that scene off a rush hour
he throws you dead
i want i want them up out of here
no king that's not you know no listen
listen listen the same way sega is going
i'm on it i'm staying on you this is for
sega
i want microsoft i want game pass to get
so big i want them to do 50 i want 50
million subscribers
i want it to be so big that the bag is
so
crazy that the heads the top heads
you know above satya and all that i want
the heads to look down and be like what
else can we buy
i want the top dudes to be like who's
the next in line i don't
i don't like buying like bethesda is one
thing but i don't think the government
would let them know
that i think i think at this point in
time the government is with this
i think at this point in time anything
can happen
and i'm down for anything is possible so
so okay how about that
if they bought they bought playstation
they bought sony
right and they let them run as their own
entity would you consider that still a w
no w no i don't want that i want i want
you to erase
like i want to purchase them and then i
want the name to be crushed and thrown
in the book
and i want microsoft on the top i want
so you want you wanna buy yourself a
logo on the place
oh you look at the place whatever what
if they cop and the sony name is more
important to them they call it the
microsoft
playlist
that's not acceptable i don't want an
association
remember oh remember the old looney tune
cartoons where it'll be like
you know bugs buddy starring
i want the microsoft logo
[Laughter]
moving on with king's evil monopoly
corporate king moves oh we got to get
these suitcases the super chats are
hilarious by the way oh no then we got
stitched with the 2
super chat uh any thoughts on 10 cent
buying warframe
so i mean i've been in the bushes so i
don't if this happened
just i'm i'm beyond i'm behind on news
so it's i don't know
i think tencent bought that whole
company didn't they yeah
i mean that's the move this is we i've
been telling i told you
years ago about tencent
isn't it the cup because sony tried to
buy uh i think
that was the same company wasn't it they
outbid it you're six million said
saudi a subsidiary of markets
imagine how disgusted the king would be
if they bought sony and they ditched the
xbox brand
from brandon got their weight
uh-huh erase it oh my god so so dudes
can forget about it because once it's
out of memory for like a couple of
months they'd be like sorry
what i'm done
uh yeah so the ten cent thing yeah i
didn't even know that really went down i
guess
so but i mean tencent tencent is scary
just
it's scary like watch out for them
hey man then we have jd gamer with the
five dollars which had i stand by my
predictions of the sobo iowa interactive
tech land and don't nod for xbox
and i'll add people can fly uh and for
sony they'll get blue point and remedy
yeah blue point seems like something
is definitely like a no-brainer for them
yeah so yeah let's put a super chat i
mean um our
crush in the chat for rubber knob
shout out to rubber knob and then the
five dollar super chat afterwards the
knob has joined the phrase
that's awesome you're doing the most
with that
[Music]
[Laughter]
i can't stop thinking like you know how
like news gets dropped like
wave after wave yeah i can't stop
thinking about the rumors that would
happen about microsoft word
the amount of extraness that king would
be
you know what i'm saying next week let
me
hold up so they buy them and king goes
crazy on iop that week
and then the next week they announced
that not only
that that they're going to maintain the
playstation that's the xbox
the exercise brand name better go away
[Laughter]
i literally you see that corner where
the steps is right over there in the
back
we're next across from mario i will have
a bluetooth headset
and i will be sitting over there in that
corner doing the show
just like that to let you know how
different the bag is
it would be a hilarious thing this is
what jonathan b
feels you'd be doing if that happened
jonathan b with the
microsoft bought sony king would do the
entire show
standing on the turntable in the back
[Laughter]
it's like he'll have a stack of
playstation games and he'll grab it on
the right when he comes over
yeah he'd be too much he'd be too much
yeah we wouldn't even be on the show we
just yeah we could be cake
it would be a public service
announcement from yours truly
king gonna drop the bag and interrupt
all the new channels
sending out all pacemakers to
playstation
fans to get your heart rate right king
that would be the ultimate who did that
for you he definitely would be extra man
but these playstation people man i have
to
i'll be worrying about them maybe
anything
they have a buy back program
give you all a s
yeah i think we're good we're caught up
cool so king went first oh
solve europe man with some acquisitions
oh yeah xbox and playstation
um so for playstation i mean you have
your obvious just one right the blue
point and whatever and then
and people were talking about koni
kojima but i'm gonna be honest and
another one that's kind of obvious but
not for the reasons people
thought about is is house mark um
and how smart because returnal i
when you look at house mark and you look
at all those twin six shooters and and
and
you know the type of games they make
arcade games you're like this is their
bag they don't need to move away from
that
then you know they dropped they they
dropped the the other projects that
that you know battle royale they were
doing and whatever the hell else and
storm divers
um and then you look at returnal and
it's like okay they
can do it they you know i don't know how
big they are in the studio now
right but if fraternal hits
and it's big for them i think you need
to grab them because
again they can give you that if you look
at the gameplay of return all right all
the videos they have of it
it looks like a hall smart game gameplay
wise it's like a lot of quick movement
it looks like a
great third person shooter but then
everything else the production value
seems off the charts in a way that you
do not expect from a from a studio like
house marks
sir if that hits they need to pick up
house mark
definitively definitively take up house
mark
now on the xbox side i'm it's funny i
gotta laugh
like what king said what king said
you can't have remedy without the bag
right the bag is necessary
i think remedy with xbox and the bag
it would be something special because
the thing is
attic i'm with you i don't want it let
me hear this
i i know i know people i'm past my drug
using this
man
and that's the thing right like remedy
games
are sam lake just you know vomiting onto
the page
but i agree but i i agree with king like
quantum story was fantastic i didn't
care for the
for the tv show stuff right the gameplay
is where it lacked
but it wasn't the full bag it wasn't we
own you bag right
okay okay so it'd be interesting whoever
picks them up if they are picked up
i it would be interesting to see how
their games change
you know who i want to pick up remedy i
want activism to pick a remedy because
they'll shut their ass down don't set
them down
but okay so remo remove from that right
move from that i think
um they need to give moon studios that
though
in studios they don't i know moon wants
to do that
yeah right moon wants to do them so
playground wasn't for sale
either yeah i mean everybody has a price
i would say
i think man and ori got shafted
yeah for sure for sure but that game
is something else and i'd be interested
to see what they do if they if they move
away from the to
the side scroller and do something
different much like the house mark with
return
like give them the bag let them do
something uh graphically super impressed
not that orry isn't but
um different and see what they can do
with that so to me
those are the ones that i really like to
me
they just need to make and these aren't
like big humongous purchases but i think
they
they really are studios that give in the
bag
can grow to be those sort of triple a
crazy studio
that's not fair enough i'll jump in
unless we gotta see which oh wait we
gotta get forte and we got some
some love he jumped a couple of yeah
we're getting some more
moments so i got jonathan
we got akw with the five pound super
chat hey king microsoft would do the
same thing sony did
cyberpunk they would pull it from the
store
and uh let me get for it today man super
chat happy new year to the lords of
smack talk
being friends with you guys have been
one of the highlights of my years
greatness will follow you guys at
everything you do just glad to be here
to see y'all he
forte is such a real dude man loves what
it says hilarious
we and what i like about forte he games
you know what i'm saying games with us
because a lot of these content creators
we
find out don't game but we actually game
with him all the time and he gets to see
a lot of the lords behind the scenes
he got premium content last night this
week
actually you know what i'm saying with a
lot of lords that haven't come on screen
yet that he's getting the chance to
interact with
so salute he saw me and sinister like
yeah yeah man it's it's it's classic
classic editing solution to him man but
um yeah i'll jump in
yeah so yeah i got some good ones um so
i'm from the uh
i don't care who from the microsoft
authority said somebody better snatch up
a sobo
if they're available if so those
available because we saw obviously they
came from the recall days and the
plagues tale
but to be i was impressed that that
flight simulator man that flight
simulator showed me from a graphical
fidelity standpoint
when they got hardware they could push
it to the limit you know what i'm saying
we already heard that's coming
and um yeah so a solo somebody needs to
snatch them preferably i guess microsoft
if the relationship is there
obviously with recore and um flight
simulator um let me see blue like you
said
i think it was you that said blue point
um
yeah blue yeah blue point i mean they've
been like the king
of the remakes i think sony needs to
snatch that you know
you know definitely lock that down
secure that they did the demon soul the
shadow of the colossus
and the drake collection joint so um um
yeah ain't gonna like this one but um
somebody need to lock down a good old
platinum man
flattening what's going on i like
activation
i like flatten them why are you gonna do
those eyes i ain't like those eyes
addict just did i
like that but uh platinum man i i like
them with a bag
and structure and uh they have no
structure
they got 50 games in the works at one
time
without the smurfs the great hey whoever
interviewed i got i got a cat for
copyright oh
but uh look man i i want i want to see i
don't i i don't know if microsoft would
revisit that but how cool would that be
you know say with a scale-bound
situation we know nintendo
has a good relationship with them still
you know we've seen them stuff come out
and then sony you know i mean so
japanese based companies so
and i want astral chain too so somebody
better make it you know that's that's
that
and then the last one which is probably
to no surprise but i gotta say it
king i've come full circle i bend the
knee you're going like this one
come back bunji come back funji
come back because um the reason being is
this
we know they're working on the new ip
which is matter right
we know the relationship is good in the
past i have disagreed with king and i've
said
no let them stay over there right
but there is a civil war going on in the
community right now
and for the casuals you guys are good
like everyone's loving destiny you know
it's great for the harcourt i'm not on
this side
actually bontis is on this side i'm
actually cool with it right with that
but
the hardcore they want the game to be
lived in 24 7. they're not a fan of the
seasonal
format they like the big expansion where
they spend months upon months
you know of of blazing the game and not
to drip feed so to speak
so you know at this at this point one
thing i have to say when bungie has the
bag
you know what i'm saying from uh from a
content um
what's the word when you you're just
moving content out from a release
standpoint
they they do better as far as meeting
those deadlines
when them by themselves it's funny to
call them an independent studio because
they're so big
but but done by the self i i see some of
the hardcore community does not
like that content drip format and they
want
more and they lost what is it um high
moon studios
they did a lot of their expansions they
lost vicarious vision these are all
activision help teams you know what i'm
saying that can give
more of the content more of the worlds i
hear now they're trying to hire a reward
team on their own and stuff like that
so destiny probably would not be
affected on some exclusive thing
that would probably stay multiplied but
who knows what would happen with their
new ip
matter which i heard it's going to be
like a diablo thing so
i kind of liked them with the bag only
from a resource standpoint
from a resort gap yeah i i i understand
exactly what you're saying
yeah right and um i think the first they
asking price it's too high was when
that's why
but that you you go high and you
negotiate your way down to the middle
right okay so of course you know you
have the ability to do so because
under the belt you have you
you made illmatic right facts and then
you came right behind that and and did
did even better numbers to be honest
with you i really think uh destiny is
even better numbers yeah i think
they're numbers they're on fire right
now i know the hardcore community but
they aren't there
engagement everything's up up yeah i
think putting it in game pass was a way
for them to say let me um let for
microsoft
to check the real engagement yes to see
the words to see everything to see where
we at with this
and then going forward and um evaluating
the
uh the purchasing because when you when
you
are going to spend this type of money
you have to see the return on
investments
uh would it be worth it so you bring
those metrics up to the higher
higher-ups you know satya can take
those metrics up to get approval on this
amount of money to go
to this single studio that's shown
a level of consistency like our boy gene
hard work dedication consistency will
bring you
that bag and longevity so i i believe
you're getting onto something right now
yeah i i believe you purchased
bungie for future ips
yes and the level of consistent
uh stuff that's coming out now now
does it change what was on playstation
no no i believe that destiny still stays
you know day and day and stuff on game
pass that that's how that
is handled but playstation will uh still
be able to access new content for
destiny absolutely and whatever they're
doing over there
so i think that letter of the word will
will change in that manner but i also
feel that you you're all right it would
be
better yeah for microsoft and
bungie yeah it it fits it fits we know
the relationship with phil
and pete parsons those two are pissing
apart you know we know
that at some point there was a you know
offer made or so to speak
and bungie probably went very high
rightfully so i mean they
they've been their feelings hurt so to
speak after being acquired to have their
independence
but the reality is as a as a hardcore
destiny fan
i can see it's a struggle for them
sometimes to get the consistent content
that the hardcore craves without the
resources now i'm seeing
not that activision was perfect i'm just
saying from a resource studio now if
they're in-house and they've got all
these other 23 studios and they're
sharing technique
it's a difference you know what i'm
saying and then they can start pumping
stuff out
you know and meet these deadlines on
time and it matter i feel is the big key
because if feeling those guys seen that
and they're very impressed with that
they may want to lock that down but
that's all i got i would not be opposed
to that
so sorry we're gonna finish it out with
you man you got the uh
some anticipation some games yeah man so
we talked about specific studios we
talked about specific games and stuff
like that but this is this is just
basically
what do what are we most anticipating
for this year because uh we're in the
think of it now like
gaming isn't the way it used to be where
you have big lulls during the year
like we're in january and we're already
hitting the ground running in a couple
of weeks like it's
we're already in game so um it's it's an
exciting time to be a gamer and so i
just want to know what you got from you
guys
what are your most anticipated games of
the year
let's get it um a year
i don't even know to be honest with you
like a long list bro
this is the stuff yeah
i mean obviously halo
i can always are you more scared for
halo than anything
else i really am like
i'm looking up the games right now
coming out in 2020 because there's just
been so many delays
like yo first yo hold on get iron man
yeah i am mike
mike back to the chat once he made
him then followed it up with a knife
did he stay in the bushes thank you guys
without doing that right now we're not
doing it you guys do
i'm gonna tell you this and this is
where
i'm going to tell you how they
put the boot on halo neck yeah i don't
want to hear it don't like it
they don't have nobody iconic like
master chief because in destiny
everybody's master chief like each
character that you pick your character
is master chief so it doesn't give that
one distinct identity and i feel you
that you may feel that but that was an
old metric for something that was back
in the days
where you needed that iconic character
to push your franchises forward
and it gave microsoft an identity and i
feel you that you don't want to let go
of that
but what destiny did and i know you're
saying it because destiny is on
playstation and
you know halo's on microsoft's platform
only but
until you can get an array until halo
have
raids where the mechanics where you can
blast somebody in the tank
or um
do you think that they'll ever do rage
yes
i think halo infinite is going to
break the mold and they have to because
they're looking at what is positive and
what brings in the numbers
and there is nothing i'm telling you
there's nothing
like getting uh six to ten of your
friends
inside a room and getting a rotation
going and sitting
engaging for hours and running it back
to
back and doing different things and
learning stuff
the best cooperative experience doesn't
have that that's what people understand
it's the end game
the raise attic you know you say for
yourself about your own mouth
if it wasn't for the race you wouldn't
even be playing destiny anymore like
there's so many people that have that
experience
solve that have not experienced the raid
that don't understand the the nature of
why the game is great and vault of glass
digs at that which is just coming back
that literally single-handedly
saved destiny because of the addictive
nature of cooperative
complex end game where you have to work
as a team with six players there's no
experience
like it period in-game i'm camping for
that that's just what it is
it's destiny itself oh cut it out hold
on let me get dizzy the fraud
arc raids better listen worry about vin
diesel in the budget before you even
come at us
about arc raids and worry about your
frame rate
before you even talk about our r rave in
the same breath as a destiny race
your timeout time arc
fraud alert drag
race
do not do not allow me to come off the
mountain and throw rocks at people
somebody blew this man
i love you dizzy but you are in the
bushes sir
when we're talking about real games
listen
the best thing with arc 2 is vin
diesel's face
i'm going to tell you right now this is
gonna stay on your head
this is you right now you gotta stop
that you gotta clean up dude there's
some cleanup within the chat
you gotta stop somebody boo this man
it's going to be hard for me to like but
like visualize a raid and halo
like oh because like you could do it
halo doesn't have the mechanics that
destiny has
so like we don't know what the
infinite mechanics would be i mean is
halo if it goes start throwing at supers
and stuff like that that's
that's one of the things that makes
destiny's raid so unique
is the fact that people have their own
support roles people have
let me ask you a question one question
because i have not done it yet and this
is to cognito i guess to you
you can answer this um y'all keep
talking about
raids inside go sushima yes it has
destiny mechanics
okay so you throw supers and stuff they
don't have supers but
i will say for the classes that they
have
to mimic some certain stuff not not
they're not mimicking dusty glass but
they have the unique lane in that
there's different character types
but it's the closest to destiny without
superpowers
the mechanics like that's what most rays
like division kind of failed at like
mechanics working together two onto
doing different things to initiate
something else
you know separating coming back to get
like all they had this court
they paid attention to what bungie was
doing this is why i actually
asked you to answer him oh i can't
no listen when it comes to the core
aspect it's possible yeah i mean
obviously if halo
applied those you listen you gotta i'm a
firm believer you gotta study the best
whoever is the best
at something you gotta take something
from me if they would
go that drastic i don't know the only
the only reason why i lean at it your
direction a bit
is because halo was kind of this single
player
thing right unless i mean what are they
going to do true
true i mean you're right i mean you guys
are right i mean at the end of the day
they probably most likely gonna have the
four-player co-op mode
you know i'm saying i don't know i don't
know if they would do anything like that
that would be very surprising i will say
that that that sort of mechanic stuff
i like my image might be with destiny is
the carrot on the stick stuff the the
grinding you're not into grinding
that that bothers me and another thing i
don't like about destiny
is the uh like the the physics of it
when you play halo right the physics
like you drop a grenade
people flying all over the place a strap
no going everywhere and destiny
everything everything feels a little
floaty
right and i don't know that's by design
right because you guys like you can
float and you can
everything is a little bit floatier so
it i like the
the weight the weight of halo in physics
yeah i like the weight of halo
but all that stuff like if they give me
a raid with halo mechanics
yeah i'm going to down with that i like
that
i won't be opposed they're trying
different things like kings say they're
doing
free to play multiplayer you know
they've dabbled in war zone i actually
would like them to take a
take a stab as much as i call it the
mumble rap of gaming
i would not mind to see what a halo
battle royale
would look like i wouldn't get that i
wouldn't mind i'll lean more towards
that but hey i'm not gonna say no to all
right i'm at the point i want halo
i'm i'm less worried about them getting
the stuff that
hardcore halo fans want right at this
point yeah and just seeing
how they're gonna differentiate
themselves yeah we all agree halo
yeah no hardcore halo fans you get a
story but
you know that that mmo or
the you know the the battle royale i'm
all in for battle
i think halo molds great to battle
royale i think it'll be fun
right but i also feel that
they don't have to you know cut off the
you know
they knows this fight they face right
doing some
uh six player cooperative type of thing
to do a raid to attack a boss
and you know do instances like that you
know do four-player co-op
and then do six player type raids
mechanics because they probably hit
bubbles and
they do suppress and grenades they do
all the stuff without
actually you know having supers and
stuff like that
you don't really need supers in this
raid in fact this raid
is actually uh you can really do it
super less
yeah this is a super light raid if you
really think about it yeah absolutely i
i get that
but like just because this raid you
don't have to rely on super so much like
that's still always been like a key
factor in destiny okay
are you the warlock we need the nova
bomb like like the classes
i feel like that's what makes their
right different than others
is that is that interaction between
everyone in their classes
i agree and halo doesn't have classes to
wheat to mind
i think it's going to be
i think it's going to come down to the
variety of weapons and how those weapons
would affect
bosses and whatnot in those races
the spartans would have to have um
that's the country that the smartest had
to have like individual
abilities that only certain spartans do
so that you can have a differentiate
like
kind of like what gears hive busters is
doing yeah like there's a guy that does
just a reload there's a guy that puts up
the shield there's the chick with the
line for the act
right if
is they double down on mechanics yeah
well
i mean it's been gone long enough that
why not you know what i mean like
why is it possible i mean bungie might
help
if bungie in the building listen if
something is done behind the back door
right
and and and bungie might give some
you know hey we are the masters of this
we are in the building
well i mean if you look at it there's
our already been
different types of spartans you know
right there's been spartans that's been
built to be more like tanks
yep right you know that they could go
that direction where you have a
a spartan that that's right or bigger
bulker yeah he could take more damage
you have a spartan that's smaller
that he's faster how cool would it be i
go for how cool would it be
halo has the the magic in the universe
and the lore so like how cool would it
be if you know
atriox is like a boss character and
everyone's gotta
team up and he's larger than life and
then you know you got four or
six spartans and you gotta you know work
it out i could see some
potential and they could have a
bombastic cinematic type of nature with
it
it would be kind of fun it could be done
man it can be done yeah anyway they need
us in the office
salute i'll jump in real quick i got a
couple suggestions i don't know if
soft's turn yet or
super chat i know how would you know
we're good on super chat wait wait no no
no forgive me
um no no we're not good on super chats
uh
already messed it up man we got the
living flame with the two dollars
i literally had a panic attack last time
i rate it
i feel it's a lot it's a lot man yeah i
feel like i i could see it working to a
point like imagine like having a
fight cortana in her guardians and like
a raid but
it's just like first off i don't see
them doing that i don't see them doing
it but i wouldn't be opposed if they
attempt it
i would too can people say that they
need a drastic re-over like
i don't mind them taking certain things
from the desks anyway
i just don't want them taking everything
i don't want if i want destiny i'll go
play destiny
we get that no completely i think i'll
jump in we said halo infinite definitely
on the list we were all curious to see
what happens now with you know
everything on the line with 343 in the
in the extra year so that'll be cool um
some low i got some low gems um again
i'm i'm
i'm the lord of the third party showcase
that people they like so i got to say
some more games
um chorus from deep silver i like that
game that game looked very cool on xbox
you know everspace shift vibes but then
it looks like it has a real strong
narrative with the chick
you know involved and she's in some dark
coat or whatever that game look crazy
i'm going cap for my man my one man bam
man my
what is it fyq something studios for
bright uh memory infinite i i know that
it's a demo
and it's you know the original bright
memory right now and
you know wasn't that the original
catfish though
yeah yeah what it was catfish the hell
out of
oh yeah when i saw the face
i don't care forget the eight dollars
uh-huh let's start off with what we
thought it was yeah it showed at the
show dude
like oh my god that's the next level
no but that was infinite that was the
new one okay what we got is the oh
i don't want that yeah i wouldn't want
that because when i saw that
i was like no when i saw that i saw the
dude face
that was worse than craig i don't know
how that's not all you talking about
bright
beverage one yeah yeah don't put it i
liked it
but i agree with king noah after you saw
infinite
you you might as well just waited and
prettied up bright memory
i think what made it even worse is the
fact that
they charge for it so if it would have
been like a
free demo you could just see that's one
thing but they're like
eight dollars you'll never get back on
y'all really complaining about a eight
dollar devil made by
one man and y'all out here complaining
once i saw the face in the hand and it
looked like guys oh
you know what the worst part about it oh
god it's like they're acting like that
was a cheap
narrative thing that you could do it was
like look this has the
s logo on it it's like and it's eight
bucks go try it out it's like why does
that cost
money
because he's one dude in the booth
this is this is where this comes up
yo on guarding them when i saw i said
eight dollars
why y'all getting bad at eight dollars
eight dollars
you are not getting no money sir eight
dollars you get engagement
shots he
i mean i play this is the game that i
was playing while all the bigger games
were downloading
all i'm gonna say for what guy i was
impressed uh
unlike dolores ozzie press i am very
happy that he has a team
easily impressed i'm happy that he has a
team
val bright memory ifrit got the
titanfall wall running
the gun the tighter gun play and i liked
he had some demon soul boss rush connor
i got to see you
one dude working harder than most
companies thank you yes god bless you
you wanted something i
appreciate that friends he needed more
friends but i'mma say this
all he did was make me put the quinine
on
his neck so now you know normal see
that joint bright infinite that was an
automatic purchase
yeah now because of bright memory so now
that i saw his freestyle i was like oh
there's freestyle it birthed the joint
that you like like
if he didn't get a chance to spit his
bars by himself he wouldn't
potentially see this is what you died
somebody saw his potential was like okay
good we get
let's see let's put this little sizzle
reel out for him yes and put that out
this is the bad taste i had in my mouth
right now because i did not know
right so i'm thinking bright infinite
right this is what i hear oh you think
that's what it was you thought it was it
oh you thought this was it
i remember he said that he thought it
was it like you know so
when i saw dudes playing it i said oh no
no no that's catfish
[Laughter]
oh you thought this was infinite
oh okay i said that's bait
yo when i saw the new face and then his
hair yeah
oh they had they had the three
[Music]
i get your perspective now because you
thought that was infinite at launch
oh okay that was his first that game is
wild old that game was like three four
years old that bit out for me
like it's 20 years old it looked like it
came out on the drink
oh
you know what it is because the game is
zoomed up enough it looks like house to
the dead like kind of like it's all up
in your face
i said dreamcast part two listen he's so
different
he's wild disrespectful anyway let me
finish my list because he's
disaffected by blackberry shout out to
fqyqd studio if you wanna come on iop
i'll make sure king is not there
make sure you breathe
we gotta make him feel welcomed make
sure when you show up you bring
infinite with you do not show up with
bright memories don't shut up with the
regular phone
don't come with your regular freestyle
put a good beat
up i i i gotta go yeah let me do it
because uh let me
do this code real quick before i take
off um
which okay here's the other one for for
the for the members of the youtube
okay which eater production show did
cardinal invent the xbox mafia what year
was it
i still got the hat somewhere
that hat is there i got i got that ball
bean hat too
absolutely while they figure it out oh
are they right they put some answers in
there
you put some answers in there hold up
i'm doing something right now
okay cool so why are you doing that um
listen so yeah like i got that chorus i
said before
um yeah another way kicking kicking
kick you know i just want you guys to go
kill me i i kind of want to see
anthem next
i want to know right with the
optimization patch right listen we do
know
iron man the game from a gameplay
foundation standpoint they had the sense
of flying face
but listen you uh i got you i got you
gay pass automatically ea you know what
i'm saying
yeah so you good you good with your
friend you ain't gonna send them no
money definition of
doing the insanity things expecting
different results this is the
definition of insanity this is when you
must
cut off the baby from the necklace
done we must remove the available cord
and allow that child to go into the
wilderness never to return
we do not need to see no funding
i told y'all what was going to happen
the last time yeah you did you did
listen i'm gonna tell you the same thing
this might be controversial
too outriders oh no okay
same thing but they're not promoting
themselves as destiny killers though
everybody somebody else that puts that
name up there's always some crowd that's
out there destiny is over now y'all
learned your lesson y'all
i'm beat up y'all laying in the bushes
we're in the last week
yeah i do want to bring out that i'm
looking at the chat no one said it yet
okay again so honestly i can tell you
this honestly
okay honestly stop no i gotta hold it
off
okay cool that game hit me up on twitter
i gotta go guard no doubt got it
all right that was working that was all
four of them what that was
no i'm dude the other two are uh patreon
but let me draw
the uh the the random code in there all
right cool drop the joint in there but
only reason why i said it like i said i
finished it was just that um
that game was beautiful on pc now
and not my that was obviously i mean my
series explored my pc away
so that is going to look phenomenal it
is a phenomenal looking game
right number one number two like i said
they get to lose structure get all that
stuff they give this away for free
right get the goodwill back get the
engagement for the game pass
you know what i'm saying look at kingpin
revenge
put a little end game listen remember
when division
division did a good one and they added a
survival mode they did the same kind of
thing at the department
and then the monkey business
yes and removed survivor i know that was
dumb that was done that's what number
yeah yeah but i will say this i i would
say that that this
this microsoft and game pass association
gives this game an opportunity to live
in a way
that on its own it was never going to
happen it's never going to happen
never going to have your if it comes
back
and it's a good product even if it bites
everything off of destiny
and it's in that service and they decide
you know what
free to everybody in
now gameplay get engagement and now you
can start looking at part two down the
road
when you really revamp revamp so for me
that gig is not feeling me but for me i
think it's it's a win-win like
they got nothing else to lose so i'm
just
until they make their enemies yes
yes and of course something other than a
swarm of thrall
yes mindless faceless let's get some
bombastic
bosses in a in a fight and get
this is the problem it i knew it was hot
trash from the beginning
and i told y'all how it was gonna go i
don't see
or have not heard any change from the
hot
trashiness whatever they have a blog
post they got a list of stuff they said
trash part dude let's see honestly
believe so but we'll see we'll see we'll
see but
that's where my joint you know i'll let
you jump into yours any what's your
anticipated joints
you know what i'm saying for this year
20 20 21 for this year everything that
was in that microsoft showcase mm-hmm
because i said i was going to buy
everything i'm my quan eye is still
for the bright infinite but everything
that was in that microsoft showcase
people
keep acting like oh microsoft doesn't
have nothing coming this year
a lot i'm like you're out of your mind
we're starting off with the medium
and then we're going to flow into that
space game that that game that that was
looking
incredible then a top down diablo type
of
um so it's a lot of games first that
whole microsoft
show third party showcase those games
every last one of them i'm looking
forward to
this year right and then for sony
i'm looking for ratchet and clank yeah i
think that's going to be my next move to
i think that's going to be the next big
game for them yeah i think it's going to
drop probably in february
or march uh because i think that's when
the soft launch
i mean the hard launch we had the soft
launch and i know you guys gonna be
like yeah but it's three million show
king three million show
yeah all right three million sold how
many went back um just be quiet
so don't don't talk to me about numbers
you brought one or you probably don't
even got one so a lot of your dudes is
out there capping don't have it or want
it
i got one upstairs that's ice cold it
hasn't been turned on
i did the dlc so i won games so so don't
don't talk to me about numbers or what
they did the hard launch when the games
are
available in stores i mean systems are
available in stores i think that's when
you will actually
see right ratchet and clank pop up
because that'll be a system seller and a
pusher yeah absolutely
i i need that game to come out and um
horizon i think they said horizon comes
this year i think you get pushed back
i know god of war is not going to come
this year yeah i think horizon makes it
i don't think i don't think i think
i think god is dlc if if it comes out
this year it's dlc
if it does see that's my whole be clear
type of thing yeah
if yeah if it does come out this year
it's dlc
if it doesn't come out this year which
bold's better for me
in the gaming community then it's a
whole complete game and that's
a a year or two from now and horizon
comes out
and then whatever little uh something
that sony can sneak out the door
yeah you know because they keep they
they mouth uh type lip
until they're ready to ship something so
oh
oh i know which one the patch for uh the
last of us two
yeah uh you know that that's what i'm
saying with the multi-player
4k okay 60 frames per second
i started all over again i cried all
over again playing the game and maybe or
put a little deal say a little small
little you know like three hours
something you know story somebody's
story
because there's a lot of characters in
there that i want to know more of this
yeah
i would definitely love like a left
behind type of thing yeah
that's what i'm anticipating that's what
i want from everybody i think it's a
great year of gaming coming forward
and i think it's going to be some gems
that'll pop out like that wu hong kong
yeah so this is this is what i'm talking
about those asian market type games
those korean games i want those games to
either make it to this side
or be purchased wholly by uh one of
these uh top three
i don't want nintendo to do it um simply
from a hardware standpoint
unless they're going to push the new
hardware right right
but i think the new hardware will be
tethered backwards but
being that they're in bed with nvidia
and nvidia has
that cloud-based thing because i saw my
switch to things
that i never thought the switch could
yeah mm-hmm
yeah yeah one last word before i give it
back to solve
um you might like this nobody said
nothing about nintendo though
i'll be there i'll be honest i was gonna
say also uh 2021
man uh this is the year of baseball
gracing xbox oh well
we'll see we'll see because they said it
could happen as early as 2021 i hope so
the
we should be hearing soon we should be
hearing soon
all right so what you got ah so for me
like i said i talked about earlier like
like fraternal
and can of bridge of spirits and um some
smaller games and whatnot that i'm
excited for and i think i'm going to
stick with the smaller games because
obviously like
obviously i'm excited for halo obviously
i'm excited for like
the new horizon even though like i'm
excited to see how sony evolves their
open worlds because i've always been
a little on some of these open worlds
per se yeah they're they're narrative
more uh more structured stuff like last
of us and stuff linear stuff
i love the open worlds the games i love
it's just the open worlds and what
they're doing in open worlds just feel
em to me so i hope they evolved that for
me
in horizon but beyond that so some
smaller stuff and stuff that's coming
back
um first off back for blood
oh man listen
it was yeah man like i mean it's left
for dad
that yo that was one of the last things
on 360 that i played
a lot with you guys i played a lot of
left for dead with you guys so
uh to see that come back it's just the
fidelity the frame rate on console
um yeah i'm excited for that now in
terms of support
yeah it better be yeah i know it better
be so
beyond that i'm still looking for that
12 minutes on the xbox oh
yeah well wasn't that in the showcase
though it was
in it they didn't show it again the last
time they showed it they showed the
voice cast which is crazy like james
mcavoy and like
the voice cast is is bananas like it's
something off the charts
so to me that's going to be a special
game right
um so then after that
um so you're talking about the switch
right and this isn't specifically a
switch game but i'm going to play it on
the switch
it's the new hollow knight oh yeah yeah
facts it comes out for them first yeah
pc and them so that's kind of
big yeah
my pc is for work
i will not be getting that new nvidia
card i've i'm you know what
to hell with that rabbit hole to hell
with that rap i'm not even messing with
it yeah
microsoft and and and and sony
to a lesser extent has uh shown me you
know
nail you can you know leave that leave
that over there
yeah yeah so that yeah and it to me
that fits on them perfectly so for me i
i'm glad to see that there
um so two last things it's me
stalker oh yeah he just showed you that
yo and then stalker coming to console in
a way like again
it it it's like the it's that thing that
it's it's it's
generally been on the pc right and it's
never been
it's never had that big boom same with
like witcher right when witcher
witcher 3 came that was the first time
the witcher really hit console like that
right we had
which are two on on on on 360 and back
compat and stuff like that
but it was not the same when you
i want to see how the console sort of uh
player reacts to this type of game
and again it doesn't it helps it a lot
if it's pretty and it
runs smoothly right which it seems like
it's going to so
i'm excited to see how stalker does with
the console player
yeah and then it's the last for me and i
know
it looked it it didn't look great when
they showed it but i know what this game
is about and king is going to be here
with me
vampire the mascot oh boy speaking of
fixing faces at threesomes
dreamcast here and y'all y'all killing
my bright ear and you seeing the faces
and the hair with the weirder my pieces
was doing this on on the joint they
heard
king their hair was like
right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
but i think i think vampire the
masquerade is another one that it
hasn't it hasn't had his coming out
party on console
and and to see when i tell y'all
it's hard to go back to now because the
controls are you know
old controls and wonky it's still an
amazing game but it's still
it's it's hard to get but go back to but
to see
vampire move forward and be on consoles
i'm so excited i'm excited now you
i'm telling you
so that that's it for me that's it for
me i say this though
and i got a question for you guys um
because uh
let's get the last super chat oh we got
we got rubber knob with the five dollar
super chat
and this goes back to the the destiny
stuff he said in the individual tasks
and all dps players
bought stuff let's face it no one likes
being the healer
mm-hmm here we go
is it too late for us to uh get a reveal
on the next nintendo
in an early release in march i would
like because
i i feel they were successful when they
launched um
the the the switch in march right do we
get that zelda
in march you know a lot of headway for
nintendo they don't need to give us you
know nintendo will tell you
a day before before they launch yeah
like i i don't
i can see that happening all over again
if it's ready and if and if
there is a pro or whatever in the works
i i think that from the moment we hear
about it to the moment we have it in our
hands
it's like two months tops i agree the
tenants move today so then
we we we because i think they hit they
sweet spot
so to say when they launched that was an
unconventional
uh type of month it hit around when
dudes was getting
their uh you know the the the income tax
and and i and i think that really helped
because it didn't launch in like a
november
where you're trying to figure out five
days and stuff like that and money is
kind of tight and you're pinching your
way through and you're trying to save it
to get uh
something because a lot of dudes
financially was strapped for the holiday
season getting gifts and stuff like that
for people
to run out and go get a console or if
you did get a console
you know your wife is probably bothering
you like you spend so much money you got
to return the type of thing
shout out to certain stuff um
shots fired yes shout out to slander
you know who you are shout out to
slander um but
i'm just saying like you know this way
when you when you get your income tax
break you know so a lot of dudes look at
the income tax rate it's like yeah
i got money to spend and you know
nintendo's out
so i think that i think that helps it i
think that that's a good thing
yeah that new way to talk about it
i just traded in my pro and my 1x
so i i got that nintendo money ready
ready to go ready one thing we forgot i
got to set this up before we leave is on
star field how close is it
no how what exactly is it
you know um maybe announcement trailer i
don't know but i'm very curious about
bethesda in space
i wanted to know i think after the deal
is done
yeah they'll do a trailer
what do you what do you think in their
stable is closest to being ready
do we get something this year is not as
far away as many things
that's what i heard like the vibes are
not far away
scott howard has been lying to us so
that's the i heard they just
they changed the engine a while back or
something they updated it but it's
closer than we think so my thing is like
king said
once the ink is dry right that we wait
they can't say nothing now
we unfilled this made the statement say
you know they still work or find out
he said but that's the huge plans for
them
as far as the future of xbox he's he
basically you're very stressed
i need to address something for game and
vortex yes please because he wanted to
hear my take on it
so i actually watched the interview yeah
it's really expensive and the magic man
larry herb
um i'm going to give him the magic
magnet gotta give him the magic man
um and it was a great end of the year
interview
uh and everybody's keying in on the last
five minutes of the interview i actually
watched the whole interview
to get to the part where people in the
in the uproar oh he's talking about one
to three years out
in the 10-year plan
okay for you frauds that don't run a
company or don't know anything about
running the company or managing anything
other than your time on destiny or
whatever games that you're gonna play
you have a plan uh and
your plan must be mapped out in the
direction that you're going to go
so you can course correct anywhere
through that so that one to three year
plan
is for this things to happen if certain
things doesn't happen in that 183 year
plan
they can cost correct for that uh four
to ten year plan yeah
there's a plan in place in business
facts right
i think you mentioned your phases or
something it's phases
it's just you just don't be like okay
we're doing this game and we're worrying
about this year only yeah
that's how gamers think companies yeah
that's how we think
we think about the present and now
companies is thinking about
future if they if microsoft didn't think
about future the great bill still will
and their back compat team
wouldn't have been able to finance and
give you this now
something that was done years ago with
the foresight
of giving you this great stuff now so
stop keying in on every word because
he's the only
uh ceo that's talking yeah transparent
and yeah to your point
yeah it's you're absolutely all fine
with that because at the end of the day
he even when sir when one acts came out
they were talking about series
that's how their dave got but listen to
that interview with major nelson
he's talking about he's chomping at the
bit because they want to talk about
stuff that he's seeing on a board that's
in phase
two or phase three but then they can't
disseminate just yet
they're five to ten years you know what
i'm saying down there
in the future they're already ahead of
what they think we're just getting this
information as we consume it and we
digest it
and he's one of the few that actually is
transparent
to at least give you maybe a tea leave
or one of those phrases ahead
ahead of time but people got to stop
killing that because again like you said
businesses work like that like any sound
business
is how it works larry herb said yeah
i want to be around for the stuff yes
yeah he was like stuff i'm so hot i
can't wait till we can talk about that
because it's all phased it's all
building blocks it's that's how things
run bad it is what it is man
but i agree that's all i got anybody
else got before we get up all
out of here so no good we're good
all right new ip returns this year
which initially negative negatively
received ip
deserves a chance at redemption by the
gaming community
the choices are hey cyberpunk 2077.
wow
i forgot to say that
uh when it launches on next gen consoles
i'm there
no next jfk does not exist a king b
anthem
[Laughter]
c mass effect or d i don't care
crack the grunt about to have the best
year in 2020
for all the haters salute to all the
lords who participate it will be up
later tonight man it's great to be back
2021 the lords have triumphantly
returned
a lot of fun show a lot of stuff give
him that intro let's give him we'll give
him the intro we give him all that fire
you know what i'm saying
what's up but lord solve where can the
five people find you what you got going
on sir
no you know what i i'm back to reality
so you know you know what happens i'm
going to work
all right now you can find me lord stop
iop on twitter
and you can catch me here every sunday
1pm
um oh one last thing mass effect one to
go
throw him straight into the bushes
that's for you
for encouraging song to be a rebel in
the renegade
lord king man triumphant return the
smoke was given
back in rare form good to be playing
with my brother on xbox consistently
once again
raining and having fun it's always good
to have a team reunited where can the
five people find what you got going on
you can find me not playing my
playstation 5
oh my god yo did y'all fix your
controllers
y'all wanted that smoke you got that
spoken yo i i tell you though i couldn't
i got to buy another one man oh cause
not a battery like it dies like the
battery is like oh
oh yeah no no no no no i thought you had
a story to tell no no no
no other than the battery is suspect
like the bat forget it
yeah you know how place it is you gotta
play with a chord
they join us because you can't swap out
so you gotta sit there you gotta play
tethered to something
i want you and then and then you got the
frauds that's gonna tell you something
stupid you don't have a second
controller to have it charged and ready
are you giving me do i have to buy a
console to get a separate controller
to just be charged and ready because you
can't stand the test of time you only
got two hours
come home get that controller
yo all right you can catch me on dog
castle x this week
live unboxing i got a statue coming in
actually i got two statues coming in
they [ __ ] uh one i made sure that is air
freighted to me
that's 500 of here freight to get to the
boy
so that statue is up is going to be
outrageous um actually i got three
statues this week
uh coming in so it's gonna be probably
three live unboxings we got kos
uh going up tomorrow with your man hulk
transformation
with um all right so in the comic books
his name
is robert bruce banner and on a tv show
there are guys uh grew up with david uh
bill bixby his name is david bruce
banner that's who i care about i care
about david
bruce i wonder why
i saw myself in him but you can catch me
on twitter at uh
king david otw the same name on xbox
live king david otw and whenever i speak
to sony to unlock my account
so i can definitely get a chance to get
my
xbox 360 lover 01 in effect over there
on the playstation
there's nothing over there i'm playing
so i it just slips my mind and then it's
like 10 o'clock at night and i'm just
like oh whatever
and listen you guys go to lords of
gaming.net as y'all seen today y'all
seen the scribe of the year
gene was here and then we also have
scribe of the month that's jd you said
yeah that was on j's book of jt the book
of jc
sorry sorry sir um jt is there
uh listen go check out this stuff go
see if it is not microsoft only xbox
a lot of you guys confuse this podcast
with a microsoft podcast
it's just not a microsoft podcast i'm
just probably
the loudest goofiest dude
that's talking and y'all hear me y'all
take my word for gospel yeah they feel
everything that king says we agree
yeah right but um listen go to their
website because they have a ton of
playstation information a ton of
nintendo
it is gaming as a whole fast and it
encompasses everything and listen i
don't have a blog there
i don't even have a voice there my voice
only is um through kos
yes and maybe some uh combat talk with
the king we're getting back to
respectability when it comes to um
uh combat sports so i will be doing
uh combat sports again but the thing was
it wasn't no crowd i didn't feel the the
flame
and it kind of put a damper on my my my
fight views but
earl spence came back in tremendous form
and he fought danny garcia which was a
tremendous fight
uh we don't we didn't talk about it uh
enough that the accomplishment that this
man had
so it'd been a a nice year to the end of
boxing
uh but ryan garcia the king
ryan garcia let's give him his name uh
definitely started off the year right so
uh hopefully we have a ton of great
fights going forward
so shout out to queen yo uh we're
definitely gonna have that brother i got
you no doubt man again fantastic show a
lot of fun man it's good to come back
2021 debut a lot of new stuff and again
thanks to you guys
you know the supporters you guys give us
super chats everything we put right back
into the show we're going to continue
improving
continuing better salute to dallas man
again for the fantastic we give it to
you
we're
but i'll give them sister people missed
may have missed i'll give them the new
one and then we'll do the new comments
oh they're coming soon yeah i'm gonna
cover this next one you got super chat
we got jw with the ten dollar super chat
can the iron lords banner be purchased i
need something to cover my playstation
while it's not in use it's too big and
heavy to move around but
i just need the temperature fixed into
the next game
attempt fix it again
approved playstation 5. absolutely
from winning their ps5 and now wanting
to purchase a cover for it for some
reason
um doesn't what you're gonna call it uh
do the uh custom covers
uh um um wandering no
xbox pope doesn't he just does xbox no
no paul does he does everything right
yeah hit pop-up
yeah hit pop-up uh you can definitely
put a whole iop
rap on that joint livestream that'd be
crazy yeah basically
i said we'll be back some pictures
big month next two months big man we got
a lot of fun stuff planned so stay tuned
for that man about to get up out of
there we're gonna leave you for the
people who missed
the new intro we'll leave you with that
we will go back to the old intro as an
outro now
but this will be the intro you guys will
see moving forward everybody enjoyed a
sunday on that note
we outta here peace
[Music]
is
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny worth the cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you're sweating something but
really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing
we let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle